parti pour pour ce stream désolé donc un
peu pour le retard mais c'est la
première partie donc entre à rognan et
firoud déjà
donc ça va être un beau match de ce
pitch est ce donc à rognan concepteurs à
partie avec les blancs et voilà que j'ai
dû gérer deux trois trucs avant j'allais
du mal tout faire marcher je l'aï juste
que le live marche de mon côté sur le
téléphone si c'est bon c'est cool
[Musique]
mais faire brut est en train de marcher
c'est bon donc je peux me concentrer sur
le jeu bangkok est pris à partie à
rognan à l'eiblen je peux se rembobine
et pour voir ce qui s'est passé en amont
c'était eux quatre une petite bande de
la sicile avec ses 4 ok il n'est pas
entré dans les grandes lignes il a pris
deux centres où je vais vite
après on pourra peut-être de temps pour
regarder ce qui se passe mais donc voilà
la position non quelques petites casses
top ce recasement retour du roi de
d'offrir aux jo mais c'est lui cyril à
nouveau fin tous les gars qui étaient
déjà leurs chevaux dans le chat c'est
cool
nous on sera plus animé un cul que la
partie qu'on est tout à leur enfin que
les deux partis d'ailleurs
ok donc pour l'instant la dame si ce qui
fait un bon boulot pour pour bloquer
l'arrivée du pion qui bien sûr
pourraient créer des problèmes sur gesat
donc avec les blancs j'imagine que ce
qu'ils aimeraient faire à rognan c'est
un truc peut-être comme j'ai trois
cavaliers g2 et cavaliers f4 toujours
est-il point ce temps 0 déjà ne se
laisse pas faire il veut faire des
quatre dons et fort bloqué ça soit pas
retour des 1 soit un peu comme fou des
quatre sûrement les deux peuvent être
c'est intéressant ici ok ex versons qui
est là et qui va soutenir à rognan salue
le bourreau qui est là et jojo qui me
dira va se reçoit aussi donc tour à 10,1
pouces et 5 jouer sireau déjà insiste
sur son idée de jouer des quatre skis et
ski plutôt plutôt logique et c'est très
intéressant assemblée c'est quand il
fait des quatre bons outre leur faim
attaquer les pièces monde r c'est la
fourchette je passe carreau nyon a vu ça
va aussi ouvrir le foot je voulais dire
c'est qu'elle était à 100 alors des 4
qu'est ce qu'il a vu je sais pas il veut
te ramener son cavalier angers 4 pour
masquer les six autres sasson idem de 4
kg 4 après avoir si sûrs dont des 4 kg 4
firoud déjà peut ramener le fou en le
stade voire même parfois suite gagné un
temps sur la dame est comme ça sur tf6
il sacrifiera comme le foie d'accra la
dame donc en tout cas c'est les cookies
son jeu est faux et fit jouer par partir
aux jo et des boues s'avère difficile
pour un rognant parce que la dame est
attaqué et le fou aussi donc deux pièces
attaquer et bien sûr qu'il est fils
disons là ça ne marche pas parce que il
ya dame prend
je suis aurait même le cje haut niveau
comme le sénateur mais bon ben ayed
apprend donc toujours est il que c'est
un problème donc en tout cas voilà la
position d'alger 5 joué par un rognan du
coup hockey fawcett a été joué et c'est
bien là le fond le sac parce que ça
couvre donc cette case et le four est
attaqué du coup je crois qu'il est
sûrement gagnants furent déjà en fait je
vois pas bien comment
comment jouer avec les blancs ici donc
c'est peut être déjà bon micro surprise
c'est que la première mais fils jacky
prendre le lead de la première ronde
les profits laxatifs qui inquiète neven
secoue la tête baïla je sais pas s'ils
oublient fuite tout à l'heure ou quoi
mais là effectivement ça juste l'air
difficile la position basse appert une
pièce en fait donc partant de là c'est
c'est pas bon signe quoi bon il a
peut-être le temps d'essayer de trouver
une arnaque ou quoi mais je vois pas
trop où sur tf6 peut prendre qui est je
crois que je suis moi aussi je bouge le
roi ça je n'en gère un droit de faire ok
écoutez je peux pas trop bouger les
pièces et un mini bugs en tout cas
calibre si ça a été jouée par les bonnes
il faut préemption prend voilà et away
vient jouer ça de la part de six rounds
gens qui qui était prêt donc à ses fils
adam pour les deux tours parce que
surtout reprend dames il aurait pris en
d1 par échec
le roi a dû bouger il aurait repris aux
6 donc elle a une tour d'une pièce de
plus bon ce qui est gagnant faut juste
qu'ils se fassent pas maté sûr ici quoi
et pendant un gundam c6 de pas mal moi
il a fait 6 d'accord c'est bien aussi
comme ça sur d'apprendre à me prend et
c'est très bien donc c'est très très
safe au pire y mettra son rouage c'éatit
défendre à tout et puis et puis ça va
aller il peut aussi jouer donc moi je
vais faire de ces six mais wade avocat
très bien pour peut-être maintenant
revenir voir prendre ce pion enlève 6 ou
proposer changé d'âme à notre mouvement
en tout cas position complètement
gagnante donc pour firoud déjà qui va
prendre les devants normalement à moins
qu'ils fassent une énorme faute mais
1 voilà donc à rognan qui a dû faire une
faute avec son son cavalier g4 je pense
et donc tour des quatre jouer mais
maintenant on va bien sûr très bonne
position donc pour ferroudja qu'à sa
place de plus et voilà au max qui
demandent si carlson fait le speech s
et ben non ils ne la fait pas il joue
pas le speech a cette fois ci pour la
deuxième saison de suite je crois qu'ils
jouent pas après il va jouer
malgré tout on ne peut pas le faire chez
a confiance en fait c'est lui qui fait
ce qu'il veut c'est pas de chance comme
qui est interdit il va jouer par
notamment le deal of man qui est l'open
le swiss qualifer pour les candidats qui
organisé par chaise comme ça il va le
jouer donc c'est pas qu'il est interdit
d'en faire c'est me fait ce qu'il veut
en fait mais donc il veut pas jouer ça
ne veut pas jouer ça c'est son problème
j'ai envie de dire mais il file hoffman
il va jouer le 960 donc championne du
monde de fisher munch est ce qu il a
aussi relayé par tous comme donc en fait
ils jouent certains trucs pas d'autre
voie là ok c'est fini donc 1-0 pour pour
fear hodja qui ouvre le score et qui a
bien joué et donc deuxième partie conçu
par quatre
et donc on a une petite berlinoise alors
ce qui va jouer la finale se fait faire
des trois questions auxquelles il a fait
une berline aux antilles ban avec des
trois îles food et si je vais pas
rognant pendant qu'un petit courard bon
l'idée en fait ces salons de défendre 5
de roque et ensuite mettre la tour 8
ramener le fond et fuite à la rigueur
pour avoir des cinq ans d'un coup voilà
assis souffrance est cité prend
j'imagine qu'ils essaient quatre dames
seule je pense pour ma défense option
qui est attaqué après qui a aidé cette
sauce une option bien sûr travaux on
peut voir ça voilà qu'il a joué c'est
pour mettre le pion m6 créé la chaîne
d'options et un ans de cavale la fuite
puis venir en le 6è que cavaliers et
c'est de venir sur ces cases là que j'ai
mise en rouge donc avec son cavalier un
peu plus actif dans le jeu donc assez
classique le classement des pièces h4
jouer
pars pars ferroudja bessin kathak
locales et donc il va sûrement venir
vers eux trois voilà et langages quatre
fils jack il prend les devants et le roi
qui va sûrement impliqués qui veut jouer
grand roque qu'elle habille ses cinq
donc à rognan qui se dirige donc vers la
case de 6 h 5 et sa patte si simple de
jouer avec petit rac parce qu'on va se
prendre fin il peut faire mais après h6
ou quoi bien sûr ça va sacrer les
trouvères droit glace et donc qui est
favori ou pas favoris belle affluence ce
match c'est plus ou moins 50 50 bon je
pense qu à rogner en plus fort en
général aux échecs quand même encore
pour un moment au moins mais en litige a
fait déjà très far on vous l'a vu bien
réussir au chocolat du monde de blitz et
puis en plus sur internet je pense c'est
plus son truc quoi déjà la souris va
plus vite mais peut-être même favori en
pâture déjà sur ce match du genre en
bullet ou quoi avon à voir quoi parce
que c'est plus difficile de gagner le
speech est saoulé delic à ce titre l
aréna bas le spi de chasse c'est
beaucoup plus dur avec ses quatre gardes
les joueurs qui jouent le des rockets
sur l'île chez stack à des grands
maîtres ou quoi mais là tu as juste les
meilleurs joueurs du monde tanaka mois à
rognan ta maxime tu as autres caruana
fouquet tous ces gens là ils viennent
pas jouer les détails tels heures et n'a
donc non le speech s c'est la position
la plus dure clairement sur internet
sans aucune commune mesure
ok donc la renier en tout cas qui n'a
pas rockets clairement et c'est
peut-être mieux notamment le roi faible
là bas est bon on imagine soit faire
gros qu'un jour ça ne jouait que l'on
ressente puisque la position au centre
ne s'ouvre pas
oui mais de goût il ya tous les
meilleurs sauf un mais du coup c'est
quand même plus dur à gagner enfin karl
scène tout seul giulo donc il va tout le
temps gagner et l'atteinte ou qui jouent
ici quoi et comme je le dis c'est pas
qu'il ait pas invités c'est lui qui veut
pas donc il fait ce qu'il veut mais ça
peut pas s'en prendre aux tourrades
durable vous l'invitez pas un fait
battre ces gars là ont fusé refuse salut
julien chess donc floue b4
ok mais ça m'a l'air assez sympa pour
les blancs finalement un thème cette
position déjà qu'ils maîtrisent bien
bien son ton début de match en tout cas
j'ai envie de dire alors vous prend des
deux peut-être d'un prince qui a pas qui
prend b2 haïr adams et 3 je pense à ça
donne ça l'idée de fuir ou déjà prises
prises qui est prend b2 la dame qui
serait là viendrait en b2 attaquer là et
là je vous rencontre ap après on viendra
vite en fait je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
du mal à bouger les pièces bon c'est pas
grave
bouger les pièces je peux faire des
flèches au moins c'est déjà quelque
chose qui arrive et 3 donc il vient sur
le trou en f5 dame prend dam des quatre
attaques b2 une fois de plus donc
peut-être c3 pour chasser cette dame et
défendre b2 au passage voilà c'est fait
dames 17 et maintenant je reviens tout
comme cavalier ici ou même peut-être b3
chasse le cavalier fait grand reconduite
au quai des quatre grands rock de l'even
pour les deux joueurs jouent assez vite
quand même un cirque là ils ont cinq
minutes pour les parties ça pourrait
être un peu plus lent mais ça on voit
quand tout cas donc bien jouer grand
roque créer un clouage champion des 4
bien sûr on ne peut pas prendre sur est
dans le pré en d2 voilà ça c'est évident
mais donc après grand roque
les blancs dont qui peut qui doit
défendre ce pion soit 11 ans a comme
tour d un grand roque mêmes mais pour
l'instant il ya deux ans l'air donc on
n'a pas trop envie de jouer ni l'un ni
l'autre donc peut-être des trois d'abord
au kef cinq autres choses métro a décidé
de chasser ce cavalier tout en bloquant
à diagonale pour pouvoir mettre une tour
ici après grand roque autour des donc
prise prise car oignons qui a peut-être
prendre voilà c'est fait elle qui avait
les prend et finalement faire coulisser
cette tour finalement auquel il choisit
d'utiliser l'autre donc ça attaque e4 et
sa menace de preuves 5 attention quand
même
du coup il ya plusieurs menaces et là
d'un coup ça tourne les enfants cette
partie puisque kg 300 mètres le coup
logique il tend les de menace mais il
rêve 5 après leur petit rock
non je crois qu'on peut prendre ce pion
voilà c'est fait piéger trois attaques
la tour il pourrait même prendre celui
là où alliant h4 pour faire ça et c'est
de faire des misères sur la colonne a
choqué il a pris en est qu à 2.5
peut-être 3b sa toile à ces faits défend
les casses b3 monk et b6 j'imagine à
quatre peut-être b4 pour fermer et pas
passer à l'attaqué ici des cas très
rares logique après peut-être même on
veut prendre du coup les bleus
reprendrait mais après la tour celle-ci
pourrait venir utiliser la colonne b
donc je serais partisan d'un coup comme
b4 d'ailleurs qui jouer chez rogers
saddam il veut faire à saint qui lui
permit de chirurgiens vraiment ces
décisions rapides on sait bien c'est
normal en blitz en tout cas ici il
tergiverse pas
alors d'amd 5 propose les changes des
dames bien joué rebonjour se firent au
speech a cité pas un des cinq six
joueurs pourtant dans aucune chance
voilà c'est ça
donc dames et fuite
bon en fait je dirais la renier a bien
fait tourner la partie je vais pas trop
après l'ouverture ça va beaucoup mieux
mais encore faut conclure parce qu'il
n'a pas le roi complètement safe encore
les vannes ne mais ça va quoi jamais si
ça semble normal maintenant il prend ce
pion h qui a deux cases de dames il
défend h7 au passage donc cette logique
après flamanville à tour franchi si
calais 5 est pas une idée c'est
peut-être ça le millier de ferrou déjà
pris ça comme ça ça fait déjà plus
bouger les pièces comme ça sur dame
prend il reste tour en l'air cela dit
vous êtes avec à tour sur la colonne âge
ça peut être quelque chose
ok il a fait en franchise je crois non
pas du tout il a fait qu'ils essaient 5
ok donc et 6 5 qui vient attaquer un peu
b3 qui peut remettre si le cas l'hiver
ou six tours à 20 ok donc peut-être
maintenant firoud déjà qui veut passer
sa tour là haut donc faire attention à
la 8ème ranger il ya toujours ce pion
qui emprise donc le quai seynois les
deux fini quand même ce qui se passe
pour l'instant mais qui avait lui aussi
ça semble logique en fait je pense ça
bloque la colonne à ça défend un peu
tout la tour notamment et donc ça
libérerait la dame sa fonction de
seulement défendre ici puisque cette
dame là bas je suis tu regardes cette
tranquille retour aussi ça a été jouée
par les vannes donc pareil hein veut
bloquer cette colonne que les blancs
compte est occupé et cartons kylie si
finalement peut-être pour prendre en b3
donc c'est quand même autre chose mais
laisser ce pion à en l'air je sais pas
ça peut donner contre chance quand même
près d'am prend d'un principe voir ce
que ça donne niveau pendule un peu plus
d'une minute pour un rognant contre une
40 pour fil rouge a donc qui tient un
rythme assez élevé puis on prend ok bon
ben je suis pas je serai bien d'après
cette côte et blanc quand même ce pion
qui traîne depuis une petite dizaine de
coups maintenant voilà c'est fait c'est
manger tour h4 ok bien se replacer à
l'attack mais bizarres dans la section
h600 vie je le redis je sais pas c'est
quand même un pion qui qui donne du
contre-jour blank donc gimd web qui
soutient les veines et donc apparemment
tu faisais toujours le mauvais côté gmt
d'après ce que j'ai dans le chatt écoute
on verra il n'y a pas le timer général
hebei coûte je lui passe sous les yeux
et peut-être que ils vont nous diffuser
après dur à dire je ne sais pas je ne
gère pas la production vous faites un
mais bon ça vient de commencer
donc on a encore le temps c'est la
grégoire à 5 donc joué par firoud déjà
l'idée c'est peut-être dans wii à 6 à un
moment quand le calice rappelons ces
cinq comme ça sur reprend à six il y
aura il y aura c'est cette 1ère dame
prend b3 hockey l'art madame 99 qui sait
pas pour qui pour qui est dans ce match
skill arménien mes fans de phil rogers
bon bah écoute faut choisir quand même
on peut dire que le meilleur gagne mais
bon c'était fans de farruggia tu es fan
de rodgers au portugal alors ok ce pion
h qui continue d'avancer qui a plus qu à
une seule case de promotion mais bon ça
riverains sans la tour qui défend il ya
les dames qui peut aussi venir par 1.5
un vent b3 donc devon qui envoie son
pion bon c'est parti dans tous les sens
mais j'ai pas d'un geste a très bien
joué donc pour bat pour faire dame
soutient ce pion d'amd 8i s'accrochent
les bonnes réciterait combler une
pression j'étais absolument pas qui est
mieux c'est dans tous les sens attac
lecavalier
du coup c'est ce qui va lier bougies à
b3 qui va sauter ok donc les vannes qui
défend là hélas de partout et qui a tout
le monde peut le transfert aussi à
davantage 6 pour attaquer verra charron
pour assembler sur quelques mêlées qui
défend donc c'est bien pour pour les
vannes mais bon j'ai un truc à perdre
son cavalier la prêteurs français cinq
skins un truc skis à b2 c sas ont aidés
ok combien de temps quelques secondes on
a peut-être à 6 maintenant mais aussi
sur adam dit ok tourbe et cinq bien joué
attac la dame au passage mais il va
faire contre dame donc et façon il faut
prendre la dame heleven donc il s'en
sort pas mal attendrie la fed à me
promener de hockey donc qui a été plus
pour les jeunes et plus de pions h là
bas donc du coup c'est une position qui
sans cette gagnante pour les marges
pense maintenant sans trop de
difficultés le roi est assez tranquille
c'était une belle phase tactique
bonne phase tactique je sais pas où ça
dernier pour sûr déjà ça a l'air
vraiment bien
ayant mis en quelques coups tour bien
sûr mandat me de qui va revenir défendre
et il transpose dans une finale de roy
qui va gagner on le roi dans le carré
mais il va y avoir toute loi scellier il
va quand même tenté de pousser sur
l'autre aile à voir si ça se passait sur
quatre mais trois leur doit revenir il
va le prendre en étau peut-être plus
brefs 4g 5 et 3g 6 et 2 g c'est tf1
dames et cheikh donc celles abandonnées
à blois égalisation donc de l'even mais
ces choses c'était très chaud comme
parti ok donc il part pour une non
anglaise cette fois le 4 dans la
première partie on laisse des quatre
cahiers j'ai trois des cinq j'imagine ou
faux b4 bien sûr ce possible aussi des
quatre finales m'en fous j'ai de rock
peut-être qu'il y ait des cinq ici petit
rat qui tourne vite je pense à 4 kg 5
normalement par un autre sens donc par
ait rejoint de ces manoeuvres la france
et 3 on prend des deux pions donc il
prend 2 b et donc ensuite les blancs ou
vouloir casser le centre avec détroit ou
f3 d'ailleurs pour enlever ce pion et 4
un peu ennuyant qui prendre l'espace
voilà f3 donc ça a donné l'intérêt de
redonner de la vie à ce fou une fois
qu'ils regardent échange donc les noirs
peuvent échanger ou faire comme tours 8
ou dams est même d'ailleurs bien
possible également
on me dit que je ne joue pas souvent
mais il doit peut-être juge aussi c'est
les speechs s est pas et pas trop comme
ça notant une audace qui disent ça
massacre en biathlon et dresser la
cadence où il doit avoir du mal en fait
je pense même si rogers donc donc à voir
ok dams et de dons qui met la pression
sur le cavalier e 4 et donc oui il
espère que le car il va repartir et qui
pour avancer ses pions au sens des
quatre qui a traité acta et cyril qui
fait bien de préciser qu' effectivement
ce sera du un plus un ehpad humain
puisse 0 donc c'est quand même une
cadence qui va un petit peu favorisés et
les vannes afin absence sera plus facile
pour lui à gérer que l'accusé 0 mais
malgré tout
malgré tout ça a l'air ça a l'air plus
sympa comme cadence pour fil rouge la
dame s'est tu défends donc ce petit
cavalier
bon on peut s'attendre peut-être un peu
comme détroit ici un juste pour chasser
de 4 puis ensuite remettre la marche
avant avec 4 et pousser les pions au
pied le 3 janvier c'est 5 bronze 4 ça
donne envie d'en 70 juste normal un
boîtier une tactique ou quoi mais sinon
c'est le coup qu'on a envie de faire
pousser ses pions prendre de l'espace au
centre voilà c'est le coup je parlais
vannes pourra sortir son fou et puis
essayer un moment de pousser des
cataractes au kéké trois rames
lecavalier en jeu bon j'aime bien les
blancs une position qui m'a l'air tu
m'as l'air sympathique à jouer côté
blanc avec cette densité de pion central
la colo 9 la paire de fous pas mal de
choses en fait
et pas vraiment de faiblesses cirque il
ya les pions doublé mais il est affable
y tiennent les cases donc si rogers qui
attaquent des trois peut-être tour d un
du coup voilà je sais pas vraiment
comment il doit donc jouer que les noirs
peut-être si te faire f 5 un moment pour
casser un peu ce centre avoir d'objets 6
jouer en tout cas peut-être qu'il va
falloir plus développés au clic et h4
gagne attention à la dame et ensuite
jouer un coup comme fou et 4 des troupes
ou trois fous quelque part en tout cas
les bonnes bien motorway la minute
d'avant cependant cette partie où max il
y faut qu'il y en ait trois points
d'avancé avant le bullet écoute je sais
pas trop je fais du mal à dire ce qu'il
faudrait mais oui il faudra lui qui n'y
a pas eu d'avancée claire donc d'amd
s'il revient et les attaques des trois
caisses qui va nous remettre la tour en
d1 nature en f3 sinon 3,3 km 5 donc
tourner un retour il peut repartir avec
cissé que saddam mais du coup je pense
pas qu'il va répéter les coups et les
vins nivat kikaya 5
je sais pas trop pourquoi bon je serai
bientôt être qu'à vous faudrait que par
fiat je pense norman kf5 attaque la dame
dont ils se replacent c'est bien joué
dames jce six fois juste refaire touré
faire même s'il veut c'est pas si idiot
d'ailleurs savez que c'est une colonne
où on a envie d'avoir d'avoir une tour
ici donc c'est pas si mal en plus de
défaire le promeneur vérificatrice
coulisses et voilà il est revenu en f1
que sa tour une bonne colonne pour la
tour c'est bien je vais devenir la série
glee carrés noirs sont pas taris bon ils
sont là où ils sont mais oui ils n'ont
pas trop d'avenir ces centres blanc qui
est très fort quoi donc des six jouets
et maintenant ce qui va juste faire un
coup de coude et de foule ou trois trucs
comme ça et ensuite passer à tours 24
ramener l'autre tour alors d'âme des uns
il veut peut-être juste venir vers f3 et
que saddam ou fait rage 4h 5h 6 c'est
aussi une idée pourquoi pas mais bon je
continue à bien
les blancs juste en fait je pense que
c'est une forte pollution chiante près
noir juste parce que cette masse de
pions au centre ça te bloque tout le jeu
et des taux refi 93,4 je pense qu'il est
urgent et 4 comme des states qui arrive
cinq très bien placé envisager cette
séparation peut-être taux refi quatre
capteurs j'ai quatre fois je crois jouer
donc il renforce pour l'instant
peut-être qui se garde l'option de faire
ça aussi pourquoi pas fou c'est vite
donc girondins qui cloue un peu ce
cavalier qui se prépare à l'échangé s'il
ya besoin
voilà tout reste 4e monaster g4 donc je
pense qu'il faut faire faut prendre cinq
en tout cas il faut prendre mesures
radicales pour éviter tout rejet 4 qui
va vraiment être un souci et voyages
cinq ans mais c'est pas trop conseiller
donc c'est pas logique de faire faux
problème 5 cependant ça lâche vraiment
la paire de flou mais c'est un gym
perdre sa bomba il est mieux c'est sûr
mais alors que six ans qu'il a défendus
comme ça j'avais pas vu mais tu peux
toujours faire ni à faire c'est du blitz
tout est possible c'est aussi ce tour f2
donc toujours pression très passive
quand même pour ferroudja qui souffrent
dans cette partie tu as dit que s'il a
ramené ce cavalier à 500 jeunes en c6 ou
le ramener en bessette et c5 un truc
comme ça même si on n'a pas d'objectif
avec les 9,5 et on sait 5 est pas mal
mais ils visent des trois américaines
bien défendu on a du mal à l'attaqué
plus et faut pas oublier que ça ça peut
partir à tout vent kg 5 donc attaque le
fourrage 3 finalement peut-être plus
reculer voilà et c'est garder l'option
h4 dégager ce qu'avaient les deux là
s'il faut un jour et f6 dont qui se
recroqueville il tant de blinder sa
position qu'ils allaient h44 maternage 6
un peu obligé d'un f16 n'était pas
possible parce qu'il y avait faute
rangée 5 qui je sens clouage donc d'un
mach 6 jouer
mais je serais d'avis d'essayer de
ramener cette tour en jeu à un moment
quand même moins bon roi charles ix est
sûrement se faire cavalier f300 kekel il
prend cavaliers échec
donc du coup on pourra jouer son cloche
donc d'être calife 3 à venir même s'il
faudrait sspa sur fuji 4 à ce moment-là
fil rouge a donc à rennes ce qu'ils
aillent à 5 qui faisait rien un peu
l'enjeu y reçoit qui a livré 3 soit à 4
finalement il veut prévenir à se cailler
partie enfin bon il le fait quand même
cher au jam et du coup je pense qu'ils
aient de l'even se faire à 5 il l'a fait
pour faire participer sept tours 1-1 au
jeu alors qu'ils ont déjà qu'ils tentent
de s'activer par la balle et le roi
finalement l'endroit où il devait se
faire attaquer finalement c'est là
qu'ils tentent lui même de créer quelque
chose mais pour l'instant ça va bien
solide pour les blancs peut-être apprend
b à venir et que tu tour à 7
sinon on fait juste même n'importe quel
coup d'autres pas si mal un petit coup
de fouet aux quatre coins mais bon je
dois quand même arriver à mettre une
position où ça va il se fait pas rentrer
dedans
il tient les cases s'est pas fait encore
alors qu'elle 5 le quai qui revient chez
level la voulait tailler quelques coups
mais elle en est où on me demande mais
de la coupe du monde nous ou du speech s
en fait à la coupe du monde il y joue le
match pour la troisième place
il joue le départage demain il a fait 4
nuls et qu'est ce que l'une à l'autre et
dans son speech s il est toujours en
course quoi alors petite phase tactique
et les pièces en prise un peu de partout
ou intermédiaire je vais partir au jack
est peut-être été loupée par les veines
j'ai l'impression est ce qu'il veut
faire tout reprend f3 peut-être huit
enfants et moi ça me plairait si idiot
tu en prends fou prend fou cran et sur
bien ouais je pense tout reprend ce
n'est pas si mal s'il faut prendre ou
prend on attaque la dame et 6 puis on
prend on peut prendre ça le pense alors
il a fait faux f4 c'est un peu le genre
de truc en fait je suis là restent
attaquées suilhard s'attaquer donc pour
l'instant je crois que ça va pour les
vans enfin rhodia qui va se sacrifier
encore alors on peut prendre 4 ou en h4
je pense bon frère biologique de prendre
h 4 mais peut-être fou 3,4 et juste
jouable voilà ce qui fait parce que sur
la découverte ici on peut remonter le
roi il ya pas de maths parce que leur
apprendrait lequel elle est donc en tout
cas sur n'importe quelle découverte on
va faire rage et 2 et ça doit aller voir
tous rage dans fait sourire ou valve
cavaliers ça leur ok pour les vannes en
fait f5 bon foulée cinq échecs soit
possible et tournage de la suite
voilà c'est fait abandon et donc
nouvelle victoire de l'even qui prend
donc l'avantagé 2 victoires à une
donc nouvelle partie nouvelle espagnol
cette fois pas de berlinoises mais une
vente classique donc qui
peut-être un marshall ou un anti
marshall à venir voir petit rock que
veut fo nocifs et c3 et aux verts le
marshall où il joue à trois ou à quatre
jeux vous détroit un coup comme ça pour
interdire ça dépend réfléchi et il fait
à 4 donc anti marshall b4 10,3
je vous fous ces cinq des fois à rognan
dans ce genre position voilà il a faim
donc il me faut ici il jouera sûrement
avec des six plus tard mais au moins il
mais le flou sur une case diagonale plus
actives quand le sat
voilà c'est ça le hockey et les deux des
six essais 4 donc donc je ne veux pas de
la grâce et classique j'ai envie de dire
mais normand rognant il joue bien ses
positions enfin il joue depuis une
éternité
il connaît pas mal faut aussi ce dont
toute la
les pièces se développent et hargne ans
qui a envie de jouer avec des 5-6 peu au
prochain coup l'anc beau match comme du
fait d'actes hâtif
ben je suis d'accord c'est assez sympa
comme match c'est vivant des partis dits
nominerait modèles d'amd noir semble
fragile bas un petit peu ses idées des
plantes j'avais quatre ans quand c'est
comme ça mais tu peux quand même
toujours bien défendre ça va alors juste
a pas forcément très envie de faire à
cinq ministères sans que ça souligne ici
pour être le cavalier votre short le
visent et donc sept blocs un peu la tour
à la défense donc rester comme ça
pourquoi pas juste des fois les blancs
font à 5 mm pour régis option là mais
bon c'est pas évident vraiment tirer
parti qui avait dû faire bien que trois
cas les c5 donc et chacun est admettre
son cahier la fête sera de l'équivalent
de celui-là je pense à peu près
équilibrés qu'une position
alors quel pourcentage de chances pour
que maxime soutien au candidat
moi je dirais une soixantaine 2% entre
60 et 70 ça va ce que des chiffres et
d'estimation que je fais comme ça à la
louche
je pense qu'il a quand même de bonnes
chances d'y aller mais s'est pas fait
voilà 1,5 donc peut-être way pour
l'instant avec les blancs ce qui n'a
rien n'arrive à faire c'est le 5e pour
l'instant certes accueille aussi
d'ailleurs sûrement le coup qui va être
jouée pour défendre le matin j'ai cette
voie là d'un me bouge et peut-être j'ai
pardonné si toi voilà l'histoire lier
les tours il se remettre bien en place
attac b2 d'ailleurs b3 donc joué par
ferroudja peut-être un coup comme tours
8 maintenant ou même g6 doit pas être si
mal pour chasser ce qu'ils valent et
voilà c'est ce qu'il a fait le khalife 5
kg doit repartir soit faire caillage 6
francs g7 et qui avait 4 ou venir le 3
donc où il peut venir soit verger 4 soit
vers des 5 une bonne case en général un
avant poste
donc oui toujours inquiet un peu
ennuyant ici contre le plein de bonnes
cases et si jamais on chasse avec ses 6
ce pion serait plus trop défendu une
bonne idée de venir se placer la cua dam
des quatre tours dit ok sûrement que les
vannes va devoir il change faille est
pas obliger les sexes et ça ne paye
permis d'échanger les dames selon le
cavaliere revient c'est plus cela
l'arrivée du kayak et cher dans votre
visa 5
j'en avais parlé tout à l'heure ce pion
à 5 qui peut être un problème et il
voudra jouer le tour des cinq après est
justement mettre la pression donc cas de
figure donc et 4 conscience pour les
noirs le tour une section ne change pas
les dames maintenant qu'on a fait j'ai
ici sont affaiblies la d'ong locales et
quand il a dit aussi menacé de leur
verger 6 toutes les dames sera menée sur
les cases noires à en faire un coup
comme eux cinq sont transvasés là bas du
coup ça atteindre une position assez
égal mais
il ya des petits soucis à régler comme
chez noir et c'est pas si mal que ça
finalement je pense au clic et c5 jouer
donc peu importe peut-être f3 etc les
blancs pour qu'il fait 5 dès maintenant
c'est bien et donc la nuque mais son
client b sets pour venir à la rescousse
du pion à 5 etc mais qui a acquis un peu
en souffrance dans la position de la
dire qui va accepter peut-être de jeu
avec un pion de moins une finale deux
tours si on prend tout sur des six mais
qui espère s'en sortir dans cette finale
là mais avantage blanc tout cas
finalement farruggia qui était assez bon
qui a bien un qui a bien joué moi qui a
bien manoeuvré ici si votre défense
basse plutôt à rognan en mode défensif
heroes qui avait lancé deux parties le
dixième titre sur le tableau qui a
dévoyé bah c'est sûr qu'il faut qu'ils
aient mieux d'avoir des bons
d'appariement après il ya son histoire
mais en même temps mais c'est un mot les
appariements c'est à dire tu dois perdre
mais c'est sûr que jouer car yakine au
premier tour c'est plus chiant que tu
navarra quoi mais bon c'est pas pour
autant qu'il va te faire annuler par
cars yakine quoi alors brad a qui ne m'a
pas laquelle des deux joueurs écoutent
je sais pas qu'on se marre on les a en
fait mais
comme je gère absolument pas la
technique je sais pas pourquoi n'y sont
pas mais on peut potentiellement les
avoir écoute je me renseignerai à la
pause sur ce qui est possible de faire
mais j'ai pas envie de faire n'importe
quoi je peux croire l'expert tu as déjà
un mais l'échiquier que j'aime accable
puisse parler que stream marge suis déjà
assez contente en fait ils magnétique
aucune navarra bashing classique
wen ans après même sens comme ça toute
façon plus dire qu'avec un connard à
quoi qu'il en soit pas donc à rognan en
tout cas qui jouait qu'un pion de -
michael est toujours active et ferruccio
je crois que ces deux tours sa seconde
rangée donc si déjà ils aimeraient au
moins un échange d'une tour je pense
ouais non on voit un nouvel onglet ça va
pas suffire
en fait pas vraiment puisqu'il fut
candidat ou pas très difficile ou non
pour lui vu qu'il a plus la coupe du
monde les grands prix il est très mal
enfin bon il va y arriver il peut il
peut il peut seulement s'y faire il
hoffman et se qualifier ou avec la wild
card
mais du coup ses malheurs ses chances
lors des trois mais écoutez alors
surtout reprend f2 il veut reprendre et
ramener sa tour en dessins qu'ensuite
c'est ça l'idée de pions des entreprises
prise en prise tout reprend tour cela
prend du coup elle serait plus là et il
reviendrait là
donc si je convoque que j'avais pas
avoir auquel je vais faire un truc c'est
que je vais observer faire comme ça
est-ce que ça ça va me permettre de
faire marcher bon bah je sais pas vous
la bon là on peut la voir si tôt reprend
un peu dur à tour des cinq en tout cas
voilà les bonnes qui gardent bien sa
tour soit 5e ranger pour garder ce pion
mais ça se peut vaciller là on fait en
gros phares arrivent à jouer ses trois
un moment pour l'instant c'est pas trop
bon basket reprend et deux échecs dont
qu'il a fait f3 tanger cinq attaques
celui-là donc sur angers qui a trouvé 4
d'ailleurs d'avoir des quatre possibles
f4 aussi
pour h5 je parle haven
ok peut-être tour des 2 préparant ces
trois notre monture tous deux on peut
ramener la tour ici mais entre il va
falloir essayer d'avancer cette majorité
pions créer des échanges et se crée plus
on voit c'est ok c4 pas mal donc tout
rage de possibles du cuivre juste bouger
son roi et surprise en passant il
prendra du roi et elle sera de faire b4
et donc valoriser ceux qui ont passé en
fin de compte une fois que lui sera
échangé contre lui on fera des 4 en
décembre à celui-là et inscriptions à
passer donc bonne finale pour l'instant
tout cas pour pour firo jaqee mieux
c'est à voir si les veines arrive à
sauver sa le coup qu'on a envie de faire
un faux calcul et seth ward et 5
proposait les changes pour une finale de
rois puis surtout reprend pions prend on
voit ici le roi ici voilà voilà
rené 6 aura des 4 arrive juste à temps
autour des cinq sens comme un coup
jouable
sûrement que les vannes aurait refusé de
ces chèques ne sait pas tout cas à
roissy de ian son range c'est logique
aussi il garde pour des cinq en réserve
il peut jouer mettre sa tour ici ou
monter le roi après donc tout rage jean
cours des deux matchs joués il veut
faire tout rage 3 et il va faire tour
des cinq je pense prise de g3 prise à 5
efforts en voir gagner ça ma monna lisa
est le déroulement de la partie
l'autre option quand même ces deux tours
j'ai deux pour juste non seulement voilà
on n'y prend pas le risque qu'ils jouent
ça sent contre je sais peut-être encore
mieux bien sûr
du coup le roi doit passer maintenant
des trois des quatre peut-être direction
des 6 pour aller prendre à 5 ou aussi
juste pour supporter ceux qui ont passé
c'est assez intéressant de sa part donc
bien le chirurgien fable the fame qui
hélas est lui à toi
donc tour h hinges joué par les vannes
oc est bon il s'accroche sur wade 3 il
veut passer sa tour en b1 et venir sans
prendre donc aux pions b3 ce qui est
assez logique c'est pas encore gagné
mais bon allez il y va peut-être le
monde faire ses cinq tours prend trois
c4
on active le roy on va vers b5 on veut
prendre ses pions et on est dessus il
avancé en tout cas les 24 ans puis on
rase et 4 comme prévu qu'est-ce qu'il
peut jouer
bon c'est toujours difficile pour les
morts mais il rend la vie difficile à
son adversaire peut être amener un peu
le roi essayer de les attraper espion
mais bon du coup peut-être quand même
tour ces trois échecs d'abord parce que
si on fait pas c'est les blancs qui
montre la tournée vers le pion donc
c'est logique ce qui fait ok pas mal ou
peut-être c6 quand même mais il va
vouloir le tour ces deux tours j'ai un
il va voir pousser ici menace torcéen
donc faudra jouer autour bien à ce
moment là donc et torpédo d'abord c'est
un peu la même chose qui la fait de
ranger plus haut et alors bref 6 et 6 3
3 6 3 des 8 ça tient à peu près ok bon
je t'ai pas quel point c'est gagnant ça
doit gagner pour les blancs mais en tout
cas les vonn qui rend la tâche sans
terreur difficile il se rend pas il le
fait jouer
bon le truc c'est que on peut se prendre
un échec à tout moment quand le roi va
venir
donc ça c'est un problème quand même
pour les noirs donc il veut pousser et
sirois 17 fait retour des 2 par exemple
pas évident fait de 30 ans un coup pour
défendre leur tour pranger 3 ni va
tenter de contrer jeu mais j'imagine
qu'on peut faire c'est 7 et sur rv à 17
tours échec
je vois pas trop de défense en prêt
alors c'est ça qui veut être juste
ramener sa tour la croix ici et jouer le
contre je exception la force et les
blancs à prêt à sacrifier mais bon ça me
semblait bien bon il y apprit à 5
tranquillement pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas j'ai 5
bon en tout cas à rognan qui logique qui
rend la tâche difficile le plus possible
son adversaire il a amené sa tour
peut-être défendent par là haut à voir
en tout cas maintenant il veut prendre
ses pions dont je ne peux pousser
voilà ton échec roi bouge surtout
relayera voilà un des cinq j'imagine si
on doit qu'il réfléchit qu'appuie que
sept secondes bon c'est largement assez
pour finir mais bon pas se mettre trop
bas l'otan tour d2 donc il coûte le roi
maintenant ils menacent d'aller à dame
ou ok donc y avait quand même de plus le
fait d'arras pions c'est quand même
important est apparente forteresse pour
le noir ça doit gagner ça va gagner mais
en plus double attaque fini bon faut
s'abandonner ça ok donc de 2,1 retour de
fierro déjà dans ce match donc à
l'oignon qui réjouit l'anglais sac
s'était très bien passé la ronde à la
ronde précédente
et du coup mais du coup il réitère
l'expérience on va suffire déjà change
de ligne kf3 qu'ici si g37 à partie
d'avant dont je pense qu'il peut refaire
là et le foot et 4 alors dessins que
c'est une coupe plus classique mais
voilà d'ailleurs il joue les cinq cette
fois ci pour esprits ou g2 et maintenant
le coût que les joueurs jouent c'est fou
ces cinq plus que kelly 6 j'en ai parlé
tout à l'heure c'était la partie entre
ding et radjabov la finale de la coupe
du monde mais mais qui réussit donc il
joue à une classique à trois noms qu'on
peut jouer à 5 ou sont fichés et jouer
plus tôt pour mettre le kenyan des 4
donc gypsys bien les noirs font la
chaîne de clients défendent bien ici
comme ça me caille pourra venir
la france aussi pour ses mains jouées
par leeuwen et voilà alors un petit
poney qui me demande ça a donné quoi le
match de coupe du monde aujourd'hui way
you lie nul d'ailleurs dans les deux
matchs donc la petite finale le match de
maxime contre du yang donc ils ont fait
nul quatre nuls en quatre matches votre
parti et et ding contre radjabov donc
pour le titre il ya eu une nulle mais on
ne sait plus animées comme match il ya
eu deux nuls une victoire et une défaite
ayez donc donc voilà une rade rodez
partage demain à partir de midi
dans les deux cas de figure donc à 4
jouer qui a aidé 5
donc il vient réattaquer le faux 3 qui
peut peut-être venir en c5 préparer le
terrain pour l'arrivée de la 4 voies là
c'est ce qui vient d'être fait salut à
al sadd r et puis bravo à j'ai vu
quelqu'un était passé à 1200 sur deux
chaises comme qui s c'est mireille oudit
donc bravo à toi une citation et puis je
perds c'est que le début métro ligne 3
cents à 1400 et 1500 et puis allez quoi
on grapille on grapille tu as commencé à
700 mhz à supernova 500 points de gagnés
frustation petits pouces je suis un peu
de lumière
donc même ces deux joué par les vols
dont qui met un peu la pression le long
de la colonne c'est la colonne ouverte
par les blancs donc logique gants et les
pièces lourdes dessus un temps il dit
ses tours donc c'est pas mal je me calme
ans il va soit échangé à amener son
client ces cinq soit l'autre plante très
souvent utilisé par les blancs s'être
cassé au centre avec des quatre parce
que du coup on a déjà les tours bien
placé prête à l'emploi donc sur les
colonnes qui serait ouverte aux mille
fois g5 quelque part ce bon je sais pas
quel point c'est évident mais tu peux à
tout vouloir prendre ici et ça enlève un
protecteur de la caisse des 4 donc
j'imagine que c'est ça l'idée de de fil
rouge à environ 3,5 c de potentiellement
pouvoir prendre un f3 un moment et aussi
c'est une autre chasse pions maillots et
des clous et voilà
mirai flou du fait partie de l'élite
maintenant donc d4 quand même joué par
les vols dont qui l'envoie l'été je
tente un truc pour voir si je fais ça
non ça c'est nul
non c'est mieux ici
elle faisait pas qu'on va voir les
cadres en fait je sais pas exactement on
doit écouter au pied on n'a pas les
caméras n'a pas les caméras
samedi donc d4 je parle even assez
classique
et puis on verra quoi donc français 5 in
a repris du plan d donc les blancs
bah ça ou la colonne c'est pas mal pour
cette tour cette histoire est maintenant
faingaa parce que l'ailier nikki être
sujet à plein de petites tactiques
là déjà il est bien attaquer qui est des
quatre dom c4 bien joué donc juste pour
dire on pouvait pas vraiment prendre
enfin on peut hein mais l'âme cran et
faire trois ans ils ont gagné matériel
parce qu'il y avait qu à lille iii
possible échec par exemple donc d'un
psychiatre celsis joué par pierrot déjà
ok peut-être simplement retiré ce fou
voilà c'est ce qu'il a fait et du coup
il garde son fonds en vie il pourra
maintenant chasser avec e3 ce cahier des
quatre un peu ennuyant voilà c'est fait
et est-ce qu'on peut pas gagner un pion
des cinq j'ai l'impression que si vous
prend pour un grand tour prendre
d'autres biens je veux pas de contre
indication à ça mais bon voilà
d'ailleurs les vannes va pour le faire
très bien du coup ce cavalier ensuite
nous le ramener par là ça va être cool
on va juste faire un peu attention
roissy au moment où les noirs se ramène
mais normalement certaines spéciales
quoi enfin on doit tenir facilement les
cases la dame peut venir faire tout le
taf par là où en quatre coups vers la
case roger deux matches 4 on couvre tout
donc ça doit être pas mal pour les
blancs donc mieux pour mieux pour les
vans quoi
pour l'instant les anglais se passe pas
mal pour les vannes mais il ya que 2 2
pour l'instant dans le match donc il va
pas s'envoler dès sa fait 2 anglaise qui
se passe bien pour les vans ou alors
dommage 5
bon bah du coup pur jazz va tenter un
peu bâtard ministériel droit et de faire
ce qu'il peut pour arnaquer maintenant
il n'y a plus grand chose à faire de ces
c'est clair qu'on est juste moins bien
objectivement il faut [ __ ] des
contrechamp soki h4 je vais parler bonne
trempe celle qui allait devenir
et puis là je sors mon roi j'ai d'autant
plus l'histoire bientôt l'un des mets
donc g5 et je trouve ça assez logique
injuste pour essayer de trouver du jeu
nourrir des lignes sur leurs adversaires
externe menu qui nous dit qu'ils
plafonnent à 1500 depuis un moment ben
ouais mais t'inquiète ça des fois tu
montes par plafond fait tu sais pas lire
les petites planètes qui me dit petit
peu de vent qui est 1950 fille qui la
conseilla deux ans il t'a fait que le
montant et l'eau jusqu'à présent mais
comment je pourrais continuer sur ma
lancée sans stagner
est ce possible sans entrain bas
malheureusement je dois dire carrément
vous à tous stagner ça dépend de chacun
mais écoute continue si tu continues à
progresser à ce rythme bravo après ces
annonces à blog tu verra bien ce qu'il
faut faire
peut-être prendre un entraîneur ou quoi
mais en tout cas les échecs seront
xaintrailles perso quoi qu'il en soit
l'entraîneur il va t'aider à te donner
conseil tenue sur le chemin mais il
pourra pas faire le boulot pour toi donc
ce qui compte c'est si bien ce que tu
fais tu as l'air de travailler tout seul
de bien vous restez tout seul tu as bien
ça si tu prends un entraîneur c'est
quelqu'un porte aiguiller d'être une
heure par semaine de max mais il pourra
pas tout faire
donc ce qui te dira si tour des
exercices il te dire d'autre a été
l'ouverture tel truc ça ça peut t'aider
si tu joues mal un type de position ou
mal une variante tavannes choisissent
tout ça il peut aider pour ça mais en
gros continuent à t'entraîner aux
calculs si tu peux lire des livres moi
je trouve ça très bien
et ces choses comme ça ouais donc
distinguer par phil rogers dont qui veut
mettre le cavalier ici et bien sûr pour
rentrer à par là donc on va voir comment
on les vendra j il a fait que quatre
donc ils chassent cette dame
maintenant le choix c'est d'un livre iii
ou d'alger 6 il a plutôt choisi la
caisse g6 ok mais il ya toujours le
petit kg 5 à venir pour attaquer ce pion
est toujours menacé la case f3 donc
peut-être un coup comme hongrois g1 g2
pas ce que j'aurais fait je me suis
rendu compte qu'ils étaient des qualifs
4 pour l'instant on s'en fiche un peu
mais pourra faire gaffe de passes faire
planter là dessus un moment
l'idée donc droit jeu il sait que sur kg
5 on peut faire est roi et où solidifier
donc j'aime bien la f4 quand même bon
mais juste on peut bouger droit ça va de
pair si grave a priori genre bref un
peut-être wash de hockey mettant donc
maintenant menace de prendre le cavalier
pour de bon donc ce qu'elle va faire
marche arrière et il peut être un coup
comme tour ces trois alors pour pouvoir
faire f 3 ans je sais pas ou f3 direct
des remet ça au tour ces trois cdo qui
m'ont l'air à peu près pas mal comme ça
on défend tous et après falloir penser à
tort ses trois jeux par les vagues
j'aime bien on regarde ce coup le cailly
comme ça après avoir revenir ici ou là
et puis un jour bep cap des 5 c 6 ok ça
c'est le plan plus tard mais mais sur
l'instant faut penser la sécurité du roi
donc il est sain que je pensais 3 voilà
joué par les vannes très bien ça me
semble bien jouer tout ça et puis puis
on va voir comment ça continue mais au
moins on calme le comte roger adverse
avant de
de faire ce qu'on doit faire sur les
dames dame j'évite donc peut-être il
veut passer là du coup comme qu'il est
là ça sent voilà ça bloque
ils s'assemblent se ressemblent pas mal
pas mal embarquée pour les vans partie
peut-être après va ramener son roi
ramener sa dame contre l'impolitesse
planches ici tout est bien en place
c'est bien il n'a pas laissé de laisser
deux trous pas le seul contre joe
diverses
il se laisse pas embrouiller c'est
important pour des huit je pense qu'il
peut échanger sinon vie mon prêt
obligatoire non plus peut-être qu'elles
prélèvent 6 c'est une idée mais bon ça
falloir qu'il prend pour prendre comme
ça on peut prendre des huit dames prend
et lui va être en l'air mais bon bien
sûr ça va laisser du dernier deux échecs
en farouche 3 ça m'a l'air d'être
jouable mais si juste on veut éviter les
embrouilles donc est juste 3g de
peut-être ou dame g4 ou n'importe quel
coût de ce genre spot pas mal ou 38
enfants des dames g4 je sais pas mais
s'il veut un truc concret à quel prix
même si c'est sûr que ça peut gagner
deuxième pion éventuellement donc il a
pris et d'un mach 6 ok donc il se ramène
à deux sur le pion pour l'instant c'est
pas mal mais je sais pas trop ce qu'ils
attaquent les mains d'un f16 alors dame
prend un f6 de me prendre pour prendre
un homme pressé de reprendre des 5 c'est
ça l'idée de chez rogers c'était sympa à
noter genre fournir le live après sur
dame prend en fait voulait faire tout
reprend et sydom prend il allait faire
échec est ensuite récupéré la dame
wallace était seul avec le cari bref
dont je reviens au live désolé up
alors il se ramène à une attaque la dame
d'un match 4 c'est bien avant ça bloque
toujours tout il pourra toujours faire
roi est venu pour s'enlever de cette
colonne g et puis un moment qu'on l'a
déjà dit depuis un moment pousser la
balle hors damas deux peut être
ouais dames et f2 défend tout lequel va
se diriger vers f5 et celui-là fait la
même chose donc plus que deux secondes
quand même pour finir déjà c'est pas
beaucoup mais il est à l'aise avec peu
de temps faire attention qui arrive
quatre échecs faire attention mais le
roi bon un peu n'importe où je pense
d'albéa on s'en fiche un peu cool peut
pas couvrir ya le cas il est trop
attention donc qui a aidé un peut-être
alors c'est 6 au pied ils vont faire ce
qu'elle et h3 bon je pense qu avec si
peu de temps c'est dur pour john sauvé
mais ayant plus que une petite dizaine
de secondes maintenant donc tout peut
arriver qu'en cette fin de partie
faut faire gaffe bassar embrouiller
finalement sur le gong d'alger 2 propose
d'échanger dame échec on pouvait pas
prendre détourage 6 attention to assist
qui menacent micky et 5 défend tout
c'est sa toupie comprend aucun cas les
projets hogan la dame mais une nouvelle
dame apparaît mais il peut peut-être se
faire contre matt et où l'alors c'est
chaud c'est un parti mais kf5 et bien
fait son job
rush 5 peut-être d'un prince c'est 3
prendra f5 donc et où damas et
d'intrants cavaliers ça va le faire ok
bon bah c'est des shows finalement
renault qui est bien vite reste la
partie tout le long mais phil rogers qui
a créé les contres chance sur la fin ça
aurait pu tourner mais bonne défense de
rognan en tout cas on voit contre le jeu
quand ça s'est accéléré affirme déjà
l'air assez à l'aise quand même été
violent à la fin qui me dit pour
technique peu c'est vrai c'est parti un
peu dans tous les sens
alors l'objet d'un côté me dit tu
conseilles quadragénaire le sort des
quatre à chaque fois qu'on joue sa part
crû n'a pas grande comment faire
d'autant que décathlon joue souvent
bondés cats est très bien combien tu vas
passer comme le 4 1 c'est un des deux
plus jouer tu peux faire un peu comme tu
as envie moi je te vois jouer cette
indienne mais je sais pas quel est ton
niveau aussi donc le site indienne s'est
pas que ce soit si original mais ça ça
joue quoi il faudra donc il répète la
partie de mvl contrat rognant à la coupe
du monde bat celle là celle d'il ya deux
ans ok et acacia line que les jeunes
jouent maintenant qui a l'air d'aller
pas mal pour les noirs en tout cas et
qu'est ce que tu veux je s'ils n'ont pas
tous deux heures tu as revanche je sais
pas ça dépend de ton style de jeu je
veux bien distincts diène si tu joues
france tif taleb hedonism sting faire
des hollandaises après si tu est plus
conservateur à la slave le nom me daems
très bien le niveau des choses comme ça
quoi bon cage 3 il a ramené son fou on
suit donc il ne change pas le chou de
l'even il veut en fait le chat s'est
petit à petit train du tour b 6 puis 6,6
puis
on verra un tour à sept en tout cas
fillon déjà qui vient occuper l'a7
colonna sur l'acier manger tour b ci
dessous des 5
donc j'imagine c6 semble logique vu ce
qu'ils faisaient voit la foulée 3 et
peut-être 3,6 voilà un bon dégage cette
tour de la clown a même si dame un peu
arrivé il fera dame b 6 il va site
bloqué un peu tout ça kaya jeu auquel
clément ni veut on c'est par ici
ça se comprend voyez que les noirs un
plan normal serait d'arriver à faire ça
un jour voir si on fait alors pions
prend très possible non pas qu'ils
reprennent pas et qui joue pour ça et ça
m'a d'ailleurs improbable parce que
prise prise mais ça me fait faire des
pronostics c'est tout ce que je veux
faire
on va déjà pas bougé les pieds sont donc
je fais des flèches comme je disais tout
à l'heure mais vrai puis on prend je
pense avec les normes je sais ça donc
dames 1 ok vraiment ça comme dame b6
peut-être mesdames un pas mal de le
faire ce moment là pour faire damas deux
pour glisser la tour derrière et aussi
mettre la pression cette diagonale
peut-être au passage même si vite joué
donc pas reparlé veulent donc défendre
fouet veut appuyer à l'enseeiht ses
pions
donc là c'est les blondes font rien qui
est normal juste prendre ici et poussez
donc la chance il a poussé sur voilà kg
4 vient attaquer le fleuve si si il
bouge il sera mené la tête on peut se
laisser l'échangé qui va je sais qu'à
quatre reprises j'ai prend non il se
laisse pas échangé donc aucunement je
m'attends à cailhau 5 en fait même
puisque c'est si utile que ça ne s'est
pas ses quatre petits c6 ensuite
à voir bon c'est casey ce qu'on aimerait
bien faire vous ici ce week-end je
pensais que j'étais rabat ou tard c'est
fait et maintenant une question
intéressante
est ce que on envoie ses 4 sinon
peut-être foulée c'est tout juste un
coup comme tours 8 c'est aussi une
option ou h5 avoir tous ravis toc et
brach 5 c'est quoi l'idée serait de
venir là un jour enlever le fou mais que
la dame et voilà je voudrais reprendre
les manettes on verra donc tour élite
dames à cinq bons à titre pression
encore dans cette partie les blancs
chaque fois il s'en tire plutôt bien je
trouve pour l'instant dans ce match
devon et l'anglais ce qui fait sourire
chioggia et fait tonner clio 4 5 se
passe aussi mal entre guillemets pour
les vannes parce que c'est quand même
son ouverture prédilection et il est pas
enfin ils s'en tirent pas comme ça quoi
alors là je sais pas tout mon corps est
répartie en tout cas pour l'instant les
blancs aux lampions plus du cavalier
bien place en 6 il a bien manoeuvré et
il peut créer des petits soucis donc
maintenant la dame attaqué bons soient
ils arrivent par la soie peut-être
l'avenir en a deux parce que ce que
donner des idées de 10,6 et joe la maca
et au passage on prend quand même faire
tour un doublé les pièces long sur la
colonne a accepté un nom d'amadou
d'ailleurs je vais partir au delà donc
la menace immédiate cédé 6 il faudra
éviter ça soit wealth soit ramené le
fond des six par exemple place qu'on
l'avait fait retour 1 je pense à tes qui
celui-là qui va devoir quitter sa
position est il du coup peut-être mieux
repasser après on a cinq ans à cette
dame à cette patate derrière sur flu
glissades et c'est pas tout simple du
tout pour les jeunes j'aime beaucoup
mieux la position blanche à h5 jamais
d'accord bon c'est un peu fouillis pas
attaqué il ya la menace de maths donc
peut-être un petit roi f1 où j'ai trois
ou je sais pas mélanger troyer le hockey
est roi et enfin je dirais alors
damascène jouer
un bombe a poussé sat pourquoi parcours
retourné là puisque pour l'instant on ne
peut pas prendre ici je rappelle que
ramat du couloir à la fin donc donc
faussée sata me semble pas idiot mais à
ce moment là qu'il va faire d'amd de
manon possible ok h4 donc ils utilisent
ce plomb là qu'on avait peut-être vu
venir et à leur nom avec l'idée de faire
une batterie peut être dans les 5 des 9
4 et jouer les contres chance contre le
roi blanc donc elle est en sécurité
mais le truc c'est que toutes les pièces
blanches sont sur cette partie de
l'échiquier
cette zone est un peu limité comme j'ai
pu et donc le rend un peu tout seul la
basse saxe et noir peuvent concert sera
menée en force ça peut être quelque
chose quand tours 1 ok alors surtout
reprendre un tronc d'un médecin qui veut
faire quoi même des deux peut être
ah non il vaut à faire cailler eu cet
assaut qui est tout reprendra me prend
alors ok c 4 c - - - en maîtrise il veut
il veut plus enchaîné avec sa coupe et
la défense dam tour est toujours laissé
des problèmes de maths du coup leur
attention
du coup c'est pas simple pour les blancs
tout d'un coup peut-être là une mauvaise
phase damas cinq tours romain je sais
pas ces quatre j'aime bien je m'attends
à ces trois du coup donc et b4 même
jardiner couple la défense et après
échanges d'apprendre de toute façon il
veut toujours jouer sur ce match du
couloir et il veut faire ça puis on
prend peut-être prendre ici et ça peut
vite tourner tout ça attention
peut-être regarder la tour pas échangé
pour été les problèmes de première
rangée mais en tout cas on aura de
nouveaux problèmes avec dame la dame ça
on va pas tout solutionner toute façon
comme ça donc faut à chaque l'élan c'est
un moment assez concrète mais dans tous
les cas de figure il ya un petit souci
pain
même si on fait ce truc de tout
reprendre vite dame prend 1,8 d'amd vite
donc on solution des problèmes de maths
et de compagnie il va échanger cavaliers
prend et impute il va vouloir jouer
d'exception pas ces genres b3 puis on
prend prendre ici père des deux et c'est
alors 3.8 jouer bondam 108 forcé roy et
femmes n'en est donc je m'attendais à
ab3 en fait bush bouffe donne aux hommes
de hockey il a pris dans ce sens mars
est pas plus malin
quel fou qui aide peut être pas un job
ligne
scipion prend vous prend et chaque roi
là bas et matt est en fait il ya abandon
carrément web important en situation je
pense qu'il n'était pas bien les vols et
finalement c'est lui qui avait créé les
contres chance de l'autre côté mais a
bien joué salut aux lapins rouge qui
arrive et que j'espère que ça va les
bonnes donc il repart il repart à jouer
une anglaise et donc sur dja qui change
de ligne et ça va être une piste
indienne lire on sait pour qui les fabia
juste à regarder la couleur de la
chemise dans ma chemise rouge c'est à
dire c'est quoi le score est bien quatre
de ses écrits à côté des joueurs en fait
le petit théâtre ici avec cette tête
d'amandine ans et le petit deux cannes 2
et ça fait déjà une heure de jeu et donc
en fait c'est steam ça me chante quelque
sorte est en train de jouer donc une
vente avec teva duo 2 pts au foot rohff
ou g5 et variantes bas qui promet plein
de vie en général
bon je sais pas quelle couche gelée
bones il faut ou trois tours l'un donc
il faut trois logiques
en fait ce qu'ils avaient fait pas grand
chose un jour si on peut le ramener
c'est cool pour les blancs donc donc des
cinq en tout cas chez rhodia qui joue
pour faire ça et son tour but qui avait
dit c'est ça de suite à leur feuillage
si je jouais
donc c'est une bonne chose pour les
blancs sont peu limité se fout là bien
sûr qui est très fort et maintenant tu
reviens décision importante des noirs
s'étirent b4 mon avis c'est un peu tôt
parce qu'on se ferme une autre contre
jeu mais un jeu coup comme ces quatre ça
se regarde pour redonner la casse pour
ce cavalier
alors tous rêvé de jouer
bon je pense qu'elle prend danger
s'atteler bonne voie la voix prend et
maintenant réfléchir commettre quatre
peut-être où tour à le 1 donc f4 effet
nival on voit qu'ils avaient les pcistes
donc mis la pression sur ce plan la
menace non cb4 chasseresse cavaliers
pour prendre là où peut-être fou f3
simplement défend tout ça alors le 5e
peut-être la seule systématique des six
cf saint caprais bon d'essayer de tricks
comme à 6 ans menace qu'un pion prince
âgé diront menacerait ainsi à la dame
derrière mais vu qu'on prend et comprend
on me menace en fait donc allemagne
élégante est de défendre ce soir là mais
ça a penché que les blancs pour ken tuch
d1 donc à ce moment là
ça sert peut-être pas grand-chose mais à
regarder en fait ce genre d'entente
tourbe et six tours en d1 il a prise
temps reprend joue sur le clouage wave 3
acquis à être un truc comme ça je sais
pas ça marche
peut-être nom mettant décision a
peut-être puis on prend là à écouter je
sais pas mais c'est peut-être une vente
à à considérer mais bon il tomber si je
jouais mais bon je crois que ça ça va
quand même pour les blancs si tu y vas
lilas les prends tout reprend on peut
prendre 26 surtout reprendre et de on
prend 8 dame prend et tout reprend et ça
fait 2 tours une pièce pour la dame donc
tour à des swaps l'air si mal
tours a des seins qu'est-ce qui peut
jouer aussi sur f5
bon ça va se compliquer à son tour à des
indes qui a validé 6 2 6 7 5 et le kerry
qui reviendra ici mon avis ça peut être
ça la partie mais attention ce pion des
six on est contents de la voir une femme
c'est que le jour où il se fait ces
captures est un problème sur ça le
problème quand on avance trop ses pions
ça une force et une fête 531 jouer donc
je m'attends accueilli six bons même si
casillas a quand même oui je suis assez
idiot en fait n'a pas vu ça ouais bon
peut-être qu'ils avaient à 8 très moche
mais au final pas ce qui est des cinq je
vous disais il ya un truc que j'aime pas
ces prises prise est prise au québec at
jouer peut-être il est temps d'aller
prendre en six sets où ce qu'est ce
qu'on peut en faire ce qu'il est ce
qu'on peut prendre cinq prises dame
prend peut-être une option très concret
menant une position tu as on sait que du
calcul
mais peut-être que prise c'est une
option accueilli la fin surtout on prend
il veut faire dame prend où on peut
prendre axis d'ailleurs à avoir donc il
te reprend 1,5 joué par firoud déjà d'un
f4 tacle à tour et si on y va il veut
prendre ses sept
donc c'est pas mal hein levana que ce
sera une grosse partie comme je trouve
très tactique c'est pas mal si vous plus
en plus de venir ici la pression sur la
colonne danger pour théo déjà prises en
c3 donc j'ai réussi à prendre sept tours
la voilà c'est faire cavalier vite
bon maintenant faut peut-être faire ça
rajoute du monde
intéressant qui est de 4 il ya sûrement
d'autres coups possibles ne serait-ce
que prendre là et pour revenir ensuite
peut-être maintenant pourquoi pas
quelques à sa mère par herrmann à moins
qu'ils aient tour ici pas ok il à faire
toi aussi je dis n'importe quoi il ya le
clouage donc c'est bon qu'il y ait
quatre très bien il surtout reprend d un
bien prendre et il ya comme une qualité
plus la pression assez ouverte c'est sûr
que c'est bien pour les blancs tout ça
la finale va être bien donc je dirais
même qu'ils allient prend aux freins
clos joli et il ya carrément abandon et
baronian commencent à prendre le large
5-2 pour bonjour arméniens qui fait
quand même
un joli petit break jouer les vannes et
j'imagine que c'est eux
c'est la pause du coup eux
mekter ans ferme pour la petite page de
pub
je vous mets un petit slide show et puis
je reviens dans mon petit cinq minutes
un truc comme ça quoi a tout de suite
non c'est une feinte non c'était pas la
pause ça repris immédiatement ses oncles
à partir cinq minutes donc
donc en fait non voilà alors nouvelle
espagnol toile en d3 à 3 mâcon et dans
les parties devant encaisser trois fois
j'ai quatre tout ça enfin il peut jouer
d'autres coûts et sur les bonnes que je
de calais à 5
j'ai choisi d'ailleurs mais ce qui
jusqu'à présent donc d466 normalement
qui va revenir rouge et simple qui a été
sept
je crois qu'ils disent est ce que je le
sais ça vous est donné pour revenir avec
ce tacle qui avait proposé une petite
nul tacite bon nombre en fuite bien sûr
et ça il ya des cinq est envoyé à leurs
pions prend des cinq qui allez prends
qui prend 2,5
[Musique]
ça va c'est pas exactement qu'est ce
qu'ils en tête surprise prise prise peut
être prise tout reprendre qu'il prend
ses trois fous prend 6 du coût tourne
alors à peu près force est possible je
sais là on va voir prises en d5 qui
prend des cinq gym-club les bonnes n'est
pas un lapin de six semaines mme banon
mais des vins très fins plus forte car
au-delà en fait je veux dire je sais
qu'il y ait fraude jamais je devais mis
en garde après c'est peu dire qu'on n'a
pas gagné le match parce qu'avec les
bullet ou quoi c'est possible mais faut
pas sous-estimer les vannes quoi c'est
ça n'est pas bon c'est la rente dont je
vous parlais en fait pour l'instant est
ok il a cinq
mais jason que les jeunes connaissent
qui joue fait il pas enfin pas tout à
fait juste il a jamais dû voir des cinq
ce que nous ayons pris site qui a besoin
de plus pour donner un pion c'est que
c'est clair que c'est ce qui fait les
vannes il a déjà de mise
et j5 qui dit la mère moderne de geôles
espagnoles c'est avec ces trois quarts
des biens mais bon ça défend le centre
ça évite les marshals donc c'est
intéressant après c'est à dire c'est
meilleur pour autant mais écoute c'est
pas mal quoi saluer lueger 68 qui ne se
connecter et coty salut à toi donc à 5
jouer bombe à la menace immédiate
simplon de prendre un bien sûr du coup
bah du coup je sais pas ce que va faire
anyresa est ce que il compte prendre
lui-même
maintenant a sûrement qu'il faut prendre
en fait parce que tomber la b2 ya
peut-être un souci bon je vais pas à
voir avec dame la veux pas trop défendre
ici parce qu'il y aura des prises et
toujours les maths du couloir formé
l'opposition et donc torino dames la
tour là on envie mais il ya ces 4 à 4
vous dire la tour pas plus de caser sur
ces 3 juste la dame s'en va où il veut
et la tour il sera enfermé
j'espère vous voyez ce que je veux dire
je peux pas bouger les pièces quand je
vous disais mais toujours est il que là
on est comme ça
est il donc
ouaip y aura trois s'affaiblir on y
tient et tient le coup 1 mais un truc
comme d'anne decis pour la base doit
être un plan normal comme beckham ça
peut partir aussi mais voilà et les
c'est sûr qu'il ya pas mal de jeux pour
les jeunes déjà retour b3 ce qui ajuste
versé 5 ou d'amd 6 à foix tout reprend
d'altran sacrifices j'en prends encore
prend 1,2 il ya quand même des pions
mais à voir c'est en tout cas tomber
trois ça semble normal a priori pour les
blancs mettant les trois peut-être dam
des 5 alors tour c4 joué bon bah du coup
je pense il prendra 3 tranquillement je
veux ça hop voilà c'est fait mais
peut-être dames 1 sera mène mais en tout
cas les jeunes qui a bien réussi son
ouverture cette fois que je donne des
six qui ensuite mettre cette tour là-bas
et qui va tout défendre je pense donne
d'ici c'est peut-être dames 6 3
la part du salaire très bien mesdames c3
s'attaque la tour sa tête la montre qu'à
il a fait d'elles des six jeux le tandem
6-3 ronfle à 10 tours à 7 soit un coût
ces trois jouets tourasse est bon pour
l'instant ça va
on va les coûts qui arrive est ok les
vins dont tu va transférer sa tour au
prochain peut-être faire un petit coup
de pied aux garçons euro pour éviter les
problèmes de huitième ranger il se doit
les juste aller alors que quelqu'un je
conseille de jouer pour reprendre après
une longue période de pause de dix ans
semble en club je sais pas comme tueur
en mots un rédhibitoire située à 12h15
situe à plus de temps 10 minutes
ça dépend aussi de tickets est un
objectif si tu veux reprendre un certain
niveau si je sors ta musées etc
mais je pense que tu peux faire un peu
comme tu as envie quoi donc comme meka
propose les changes des dames
bon ce n'est pas idiot h5 look est donc
à faire une pierre deux coups salle en
place la bonne structure sûr c'était là
le roi qui empêchera les blancs prendre
de l'espace et ça évitera les problèmes
de huitième ranger mais bon j'imagine
que firent hodja veut prendre qui on
prend 20 mètres la tour ici
mais bon jusque les bonnes varna presse
à tour lui-même là bas qu'il a pris puis
on prend pour ces 3 3bis tu vois là et
il va maintenant je pense comme ça
aurait fait ok maintenant les vannes sur
mon jeu voilà donc tu sauras petit à
petit j 5 tours b 3 je pense qu'on peut
changer c'est ton père et puis à 3 2 6
semble logique
nous avons eu six mois
donc j'ai quatre plutôt choisi par les
bonnes donc il fixe la structure de
pions adverse
ces quatre je vais partir au jo donc en
gros écrit blanc il peut donc se crée un
pion passé ici c'est clair et aussi donc
son roi peut sera menée en direction de
deux à trois fois à 5 contre 3 dessins
force un peu les événements j'ai
l'instant que il peut juste reprendre je
capture de moins ça doit aller c'est ce
qu'ils décident de faire d'ailleurs
transmis cette finale qui doit savoir
nulle où il ya un pion plus mais qui sur
la colonne des donc le roi est très
proche et aussi pour faire des échecs
est toujours visée espion mais ok la
division pas évidente à prendre celle de
lehman qui a deux filles un pion quand
même
mais bon qui veut être juste bombardé
des chagossiens exceptions en tout cas
ils jouent pour l'activité
on va te faire un truc pénible à
défendre donc tous rêvent 3 pourquoi pas
de tourner deux pour tous défendant mais
à paris c'est trop pour cet événement
nous tour à cinq attaques h5
on s'est peut-être pas vital mais toute
la rangée 6 semble facile à défendre en
cas d'échec ici je veux repartir ou
mettre ses pions hexis donc pas de souci
thouars des deux tours derrière lui on
défend un peu tout tour un bon tournant
la revoilà
et puis il s'est lancé seul un petit à
petit trois des quatre bons points sans
sa menace pas grand chose mais vous pour
h un tour 1 à 2 on va lire le prendre je
pense
voilà c'est fait il faut repartir et que
cette tour sûrement
f5 tu jouais à peut-être que faire f 5
ça casse est ici pour nous étions passés
au quai peu trash 4 pourquoi pas on ne
peut l'y reprendrait ficap tout de suite
c'est un pion qu'on peut prendre plus
tard d'ailleurs il a fait des 4 ok ça
partira une course mais donc tourache un
des cinq tours l'un des six tours 8 17
ans ma chance
il invente huitième champion d'air
qu'est ce que tu attends ça va vite on
l'autre option c'est de dire par là
3 bien joué ça c'est moi prise prise
prix discret de jambes à celje y
poussent ok j'ai deux faut faire quand
j'ai trois rois sur la commune f et h
devenir mais bon il y aura quand même
pas mal d'options
ça peut être évidence position mais je
dirais moi le jeu payne et de cases il
va pousser nous pas obligé parce qu'en
fait tu iras ça qui arrive damas
maintenant il va c'est de faire une
sorte de forteresse mais je pense c'est
d'autres gagnants où déjà il ya chaque
est prise soit gagnant mais c'est pas
facile à faire énormément on arrive à
gagner ce puits en pet ceni une
sélection est très bas parce qu'on veut
pas trop basse et par derrière là en
fait y aura toujours des échecs derrière
donc il doit arriver à gagner des six
les bonnes
petit à petit on va voir comment il va
techni fier tout ça il a une minute et
qu'elle contre seulement 4 5 secondes
donc difficile pour faire aux jo mais en
tout cas
lieven impressionnant encore une pince
partie qui semblait devoir défendre
final un peu chiante et qui a tourné ça
en même temps il obtient également cette
position donc
c'est quelque chose que d'un v6 de mme
bessette peut-être bon leur a coupé en
tout cas je sais pas c'est pas dit qu'il
va arriver à nous la gagner mais en tout
cas c'est lui qui joue pour le bien à
tomber bon eh ben ça fait 6 à 2 il n'y a
en tout cas très bonne partie de l'est
va naître
donc il ajouté je pense que peut-être on
va pouvoir se faire la pause
j'imagine non pas encore je ne sais pas
car c'est j'ai pas le chrono en fait et
donc 6 2 nouvelles anglaise
un jouet par par lorgnant et ouais le
tour problème de comme dit jojo
fantastique très joli et donc méfiant
jarrett qui cherche absolument à trouver
un minime qui veulent perdre de tenir
donc les rangs d'une catalan ok cette
news encore minime yakoko ok c'est bon
ça va donc du coup c'est sûrement la
dernière par contre avant la pause mais
sélective ce soir la pub si on la mettra
après est inquiète pas reste encore sept
mille âmes supporter et ça va plus il
arrive enfin la délivrance quoi donc
petit catalan et on va voir donc si
cette fois-ci fier aux peu peut tenir il
pas loin en fait dans les parties mais à
moins oignons juste mieux comme née du
coup bah du coup ça commence à faire
cher 62.7 sacrée avance fouet trois
bombes logiques 1 et se développe il
commence à viser un peu les pions là-bas
peut-être il garde l'option de lancer un
petit à 5 au bon moment alors c'est
quand même à quoi regarder à 5 mais
j'imagine qu'ils surent hassen qui veut
peut-être prendre là mais ce qui a passé
intermédiaire peut-être c'était pas
en tout cas les votes qui a joué à cinq
et pose une question assez juste de
prendre ça donc soit faussée 7 pour
défendre soit je pensais que voulait
faire bouger deux rangées de et bouger
la tour en fait sur flu j'ai deux filles
a pu en prendre intermédiaire donc donc
des cinq jouer au hockey
maintenant la dame soit bon j'aurais dit
dam des cartes en fait vous prend j'aime
pas sont rangés 2 si on prend la tour il
prend ici on reprend est ok la dame met
une petite pression là bas céline qu'il
a choisi de jouer c'est mal et
intéressant après avoir si on peut faire
fructifier mais en tout cas ça paralyse
un peu ce cavalier la dame a peu chiante
comme suit donc peut-être qu'il va se
balader là bas et il défend son pion
passage et sa logique et lui faut le
développer peut être ici standards du
tour c'est un bon 6 à 3 c'est pas la
case rêver mais ma foi bon ok on peut
leur en d2 cela dit c'est quand même pas
mettre ce qui a été deux dames c6 est
soit en euros sont fera cavalier là on
tient à peu près donc
wac et des 205 ou alors il est reparti
que saddam mais du coup c'est un peu
c'est que ça va pour fuir ou jack
si on a fait tous ces efforts pour avoir
aidé avant à cette exigence se
retrouvent à partir aussi vite à leur
tour des huit autres objets la dame
j'imagine bon leur choix a peut-être
juste dame c3 pour une petite finale où
aller là bas notre dame c3 le plus
simple quidam acheter bon je reviens
petit d'homme beissat quinquennat bon ok
on se doute qu'il va voir mais toute
façon la dame elle est bien placée sous
un contrôle peu de cassure des vallons
s'enlève cette colonne ouverte où elle
peut se faire chasser donc la bourse ces
raisons sont pas mal
alors fausse est joué par ferroudja qui
assureront il continue parquet des cinq
au prochain coup éviter cette fois
encore un sens qui est pas mal sur job
dans cette partie mais ça suffit pas
printemps
calais 2 donc j'imagine que s'il a fait
face pour faire cailler des cinq quand
même mais qui laisse un extrait qu'on
peut faire bouger 5 ou juste dame 4.3.3
on se tenir à peu près qui essaient 6
jouer donc peut-être tour c'est un qui a
et b 3 ok ça permet de défendre ses
pions et aussi d'autres aspects de
devenir bondir cette case et viser à 6
saint jean 5
je vais partir au jo bon c'est toujours
plus agréable pour les marches pour la
position 7 3g dos une idée m
en fait pourquoi j'ai d'aussi jusque 5
ou 6 et découvre la dame donc le jour
lequel il va bouger
il faudra pas forcément ceux qu'on les
dommages trop quoi donc voilà j'ai tour
c'est en tout cas clouage dame f5 et des
choses compliquées commencent à arriver
parce que le cahier sait si cette
emprise mais je pense que les turcs et
j'ai quatre attaques la dame menace st
mais bon il ya quand même de me prendre
le set
donc ce que c'est si grave en fait non
alors dati veut tout cas y est la france
et si ce qui est des cinq ou va la dame
médiation fatale va nulle part
mais ce qu'on appelle g4 qui prend 3 ras
bord et non pas terrible joli d'un livre
5 1 je pense surtout reprend celle ci si
vous juste faire ça du coup problème
d'ailleurs outre autre français si ce
temps faites là il veut juste attrapé la
dame je pense quand même qu'il y ait des
5 c'est que la rançon intentions parce
que la dame serait attaqué donc par le
flou acadamy si on contrôle les cases de
fitte par là et j'ai capable aussi
précis pas possible enfin je t'aime tant
rouge un problème partout donc la focale
urgemment entre des solutions pas simple
alors il a bougé le roi va peut-être
penser ici alors qui distingue c'est
quoi la suite du coup
je sais pas qui les inquiète fort pour
les noirs qui est des cinq es14 aussi
d'ailleurs je sais pas weaver votre
petite fille de la dame sont pas
terribles et les 5 et 4 les deux cas de
figure on sait qu'on n'est pas bien la
dame et l'ont complètement galère alors
il va peut-être vouloir suivre par g4 je
dire à un moment on perd pas la dame
parce qu'on contre attaque c'est l'heure
d'une case mais au pire des cas par les
noirs prennent et vont prendre le fouet
avoir juste une bien meilleure structure
ça c'est au pire des cas donc
faire juste excellent pour les noirs un
coup comme quai des cinq giret et g4 on
peut manger ou même qui a aidé 5 g 4
peut-être juste à me 4 ça semblait même
très dur pour les blancs il ya peut-être
pas de gain complètement direct mais
juste une gros avantage noir dans la
position
il a peut-être et on va voir comment ça
se poursuit tout ça et c'est lyon 2 al
déjà 6 2 début canon de la part de
l'even un peu plus de mal dans cette
partie mais quand bien même a63 à la fin
ce serait quand même très bonne
prestation pour lui mais bon c'est pas
encore perdu juste saddam a l'air assez
dans les pâquerettes en h4 et c'est pour
ça que je me tente beaucoup cavaliers h4
j'en ai découvert dans la dame a mal
géré quoi la dame n'aurait aucune case
est le seul coup ce serait du g4 et donc
je m'attendais à des fous cran prises
fermes prises ici avec une meilleure
structure même si en fait ça reste à
voir ce que star structure en a qu'un
lui qui va arriver attaqué ça enfin bull
autres industries
mais bon peut-être qu'ils aient des 5 g
4 dames e4 sinon c'est quand même autre
option donc donc avoir toujours est-il
cyril 10 kg 4e à toi qui les ai quatre
peut-être mais alors il fera dame l'a
donc là je pense qu'il va faire j'ai
quatre quasi obligé il à faire et je
pense à 2004 à l'effet d'un v6 du coup
il va pouvoir rapatrier sa dame ici
l'allemagne arrive là pardon je dis
n'importe quoi la face c'est peut-être
nous pas si dramatique puisque après du
requiem du en l'air wayne ou même g3
quand même ou d'un match sans fin ouais
on donne quelque part c'est pas brillant
pour les blancs et c'est peut-être juste
pas foutu mais pas vrai on recueille 6,5
jouer surprise il veut prendre cette
dame laïque aime toujours ce cavalier
emprise donc une nouvelle fois à rognan
en difficulté qui bloque kitsch à se
démener et à rendre la table son
adversaire pas évidente
moins de trente secondes on profite
rotja ça se voit qu'il est censé être
mieux mais bon faut finir quand même
c'est pas loin d'être fait loin d'être
fou proches cadre qui va prendre il
maintenant huit reprises attention je
sais même pas s'il est encore moins bien
en fait à rognan mélange est à dire
j'ai peut-être tort des six semaines
tours s'est vite
ok bon ba et ba dont le scav aline
sûrement revenir la huawei dans les
petites tactiques et lorient il va
encore faire tomber aux collaborations
en français vie tu vas faire qualifier
cinq épreuves à six il va gagner en fait
cette partie incroyable quoi si c'est
condamner un caïd et trois sur man who
killed web ont gêné ok les amitiés des
trois sont juste très simple on prend
lui au prochain
et puis on fera b4 et puis voilà quoi
qu'il y avait un coût et que 1 100e
foulard wave 2 pourquoi pas vous même
temps pipe attendra d'eux on l'a ce 3 et
puis en option lorsqu'elle revient juste
la foule prend au roi bouge
voilà où la en raideur dans l'accueil c4
double attaque b3 est tombé à écouter
7,2 du coup la ccrc dans cette partie
calme n'était peut-être pas de perdre
sireau déjà mais met donc voilà on dit
et ce qui n'est pas être prêt le 6 qui
gagne une pièce je crois pas en fait
hier c'était ce moment-là nous fait une
bouffe celle là mais lui était sans
défense
du coup ça l'est c'est quand même la
tour arrivait alors c'est peut-être
mieux parce qu'on avait dans la partie
c'est pas top ce qui s'est passé mais en
tout cas en tout cas voilà bon du coup
je crois que c'est la pause
eh ben on va la prendre et je reviens
dès que ça recommence à tout de suite je
vous envoie enfin la pub va être content
du coup voilà a tout de suite
vous
[Musique]
on
je suis de retour du coup c'est toujours
un peu la pause pour les joueurs mais
dont on peut discuter pendant cet
interlude donc bientôt sa est la phase
des parties en trois minutes
donc c'est un peu plus vite
voilà j'espère vous avez bien mais les
pulls du mini man un film allez voir au
ciné dyke will smith jeune contrôle
smith 50 ans et
les pub axe aussi parce qu'on me dit ok
masse fresco masse attractive aux 6 6
mais c'est passé pour mvl fabié eu nul
nul nul donc quatre parties 4 nuls et
demain il y aura les départage donc à
partir de midi
family et puis on sera en sera là donc
pour en voir pour voir ce à quoi donc
sur search eskom
à partir donc de 2010 et puis après je
crois que dans l'après midi je crois que
ça vous regarde 16 heures il y aura des
fiches à random les quarts-de-finale en
fait de qualificatifs pour la coupe du
monde
enfin ok je sais pas trop con ça marche
mon gros à la fin du mois il ya un truc
en norvège de fisher 960 ou karl scène
prend part et ce sera pour le titre de
champion du monde de fisher voilà jean
random est donc fausse qualifier et donc
ça à partir de
de demain ces centres à sion ce week-end
donc des matchs avec des gens qui seront
qualifiés etc et qui donc qui ronge et
tout ça en norvège à la fin du moins
l'horaire fable est correct du chat
mondes décidé de faire grève si vous
passez pas plus de pub à la place de ce
type aux échecs la ré écoute
j'en mettrais plus alors ok si c'est ça
la demande d'autre que de la pub tout le
temps qu on devrait faire un vote quoi
c'est qu'elles veulent organiser un
petit sondage
est-ce que provient le seul français qui
participent à l ail l'ophlm année je
sais pas frantz capa j'ai même pas
réaliste celui-ci pas je peux regarder
j'ai parlé sur mon téléphone et je vais
te dire ce qu'il en est allé l'oph man
show man show open 2010 9 à l'ope
on est dessus
[Musique]
donc je passe des joueurs on joue pas le
blabla
e
bon dit - comment faire autant
c'est pas dur de faire je vais peut-être
la version mobile qui pourrit majeurs et
deux mineurs ou spleen grand de suisse
fit des qualifiés alors qu'arsène joue
qu'à roanne âge où se jouent à nom de yu
cardiaque ingrid choc à rognan krishna
artemiev fnaca je te laisse vite yougov
siedler wang hao books angie oui visite
c'est très fort le kwang matelas cov
vous cap tournant face à la fin
et donc est passée juste juste y
perfectionne chanque la mine du boeuf
aux elle ignore kiev dans des lieux
jones kamski rothstein dragueur viejo
mcshane berkesse fils joseph sarr ipsach
ici en ai dit 'je korobov hampton allez
c'est reparti donc d 4d je regarde alice
% je vois que macro c'est vrai comme
français la croix
voilà sûrement sûrement dû coupe tu as
raison est que juste etienne va
représenter les français là bas donc pas
de 4 pas d'espagnoles mais des quatre
dans cette partie et une catalane
très bien avec une petite vente
finalement choisi par par les bonnes
avec donc le cookie et b17 mais on verra
ce que ça donne
non c'est 5 jouait donc les pions
pendant à moins qu'ils prennent une
pièce avec un chemin isolé mais puis on
prend dans sa logique eux
et donc chez rhodia qui essaie de mettre
la pression sur les pions pourront faire
avancer un et créer un peu des trous
dans la position adverse qui était la
pièce préférée de petrossian votre avis
eh ben je sais pas le pianiste marie ces
vagues il participe non je pense pas
enfin j'ai pas vu mais j'ai pourquoi les
russes truc mais bon peut-être et à 5
dont je veux parler vannes qui veut
tenter de venir taquiner un peu la
structure comme ça à un moment donné du
jeu pour sa tour est aussi parfois le
fou pour revenir sur astiz lawrence
temps c'est pas le moment puisqu'il doit
défendre ici même et on qui ça ça peut
servir aussi pour transférer une tour ou
quoi à 4 jouer donc bien normal
cavalier a eu un genou pouvait changer
une fois là et qui après faudra passer
la défense de ce pion moi d'avoir fait
cavalier psy donc défend le pion donc je
rappelle le score en partie en cinq
minutes c'est très très bien passé port
pour à rognan qui mène 7 points 2 vous
pouvez voir les scores juste à côté des
joueurs donc il ya un petit set à côté
de la tête de l'even 2 pour fear hodja
donc gros gros avantage pris par jour
arméniens mais les cadences vont
s'accélérer
est ce qu'on pense et finalement plus la
corse va aller vite plus ça doit être un
avantage de fuir ou déjà donc reste à
voir s'il avance prise par les bonnes va
être suffisante ou pas en tout cas pour
l'instant il a fait grosse impression
par le niveau de jeu et tout ça il a
l'air quand même une classe au dessus
pour l'instant les vannes en tout cas
dans ce qu'on voit sur le début de ce
match
depuis quasiment deux heures maintenant
dame prend b3 du coup le fourbe et cette
attaque est donc grosse pression sur sur
le plan des 5 mai pour l'instant quand
même pas mal tenue juste peut-être ce
que compte faire si rogers ensuite ces
juifs ou prend 1,6 à un moment ça va
enlever un des défenseurs du pion et
pour venir donc le capturer puisqu'il l'
attaquent à fond avec son fou g2 la tour
ici et saddam
voilà bon après bien sûr s'il faut pas
oublier ce qui après prise prise vous
prend prend tout ça il y aura eu deux
qui se rendait avec le fou sera passé en
existe donc ça va être si simple non
plus à faire des retours bébittes pas
mal joué ils créent un vis-à-vis et donc
faut prendre six ou pro 9,6 il faut
prendre des cinq de faire vous prend
maintenant on attaque voilà il va
prendre 2 à la fin je pense dame prend
des cinq temps reprend des cinq tours
prend les deux peut être l'idée de les
vannes quoi faire pour preuve de direct
on a vu dans ce sens la sq logique voilà
il va prendre à deux et nuls normalement
il a pas prêts à y parle je suis un peu
idiot j'ai oublié votre du couloir j'ai
cru que la tauromachie forcément celle
en a 2 elle est plus là bas donc bon bah
pour l'instant sur jack garde son pion
de plus ça peut être tout simplement
l'activité l'autre tour peut venir se
joindre à celle la seconde rangée par
exemple donc il choisit de jouer comme
ça nous pour passer les tours ici et
écoutez c'est pas mal mais bon j'ai déjà
dit petite chance nous avec son petit
point de plus
moi j'ai cette voie les deux peut-être
h5 un moment et tours à huit jouer ça va
pas être simple quand même pour les
blancs de progresser parce que comment
on fait pour ans espion bon je pense que
refuser l'échangé c'est logique pour 17
pourquoi pas autour d'eux ils blindes
torah 3 et black hawk et logique
cavaliers là donc il veut qu'on sera
amené ici voir là mais vont sûrement c4
pour dégager la tour de là et ça fera un
premier progrès h5 donc je normal
cavalli eu qu'à demi je pense qu'on peut
se laisser changer ce qu'on fait c'est
pas très grave
trois sets d'ailleurs c'est ce que
laisse faire leeuwen donc menace
fourchette en bessin pas se prendre de
petites chypre comme ça tu auras 6 qui
avait des chèques
roy sports et fitch qui s'avale e fois
défendu donc il n'y a pas trop de dégâts
mais peut-être on va voir comment ça
évolue pour l'instant tout cas ça me
semble devoir bien se tenir pour les
jeunes mais évidemment de cavalli peu
gigoter faire des choses et puis grosse
avance à la pendule profit rojas a noté
un plus de 30 secondes pour les vannes
contre une bonne minute trente pour
offrir aux jo donc il peut il le faire
craquer aussi à la pendule
ok donc ni poupak ski qui nous dit que
marie sevain guînes wild card pour les
jouets les fans mais coûte tant mieux
pour elle c'est un beau tournoi joué
donc cool que la wild card après c est
dur en réformant le moral quand ça se
passe mal
quand même enchaîné les parties mais
c'est un beau tournoi ce genre toi on a
des wild cards je te tiens c'est marrant
j'aurais pu essayer de jouer quoi mais
bon comme je dis aujourd'hui concerne
chesnais des défaites c'est mon angle
donc à plus ultra peut-être tour 17
jouable pour pour ferroudja voilà et
c'est pas évident parce qu'il ya celui
là qui en l'air maintenant il va prendre
à deux quand même mais
mais bon ben on troque pour les blancs
tout cas ce qui a valu d'être plus à
l'aise quand il ya des pions que sur une
aile peut-être mettre un peu le roi dans
des réseaux de maths des choses comme ça
donc il peut travailler autour
ok bien je dors assad qui vit pour
l'instant cavalier ou six j'aime bien un
petit fou et 5 un moment touré fuite
donc il y aussi ceux arrivés mais pour
l'instant le fou ce qui fait bien ce
qu'ils contrôlent limmat peut-être par
là bas un jour
donc c'est pas encore désespérée pour
les vannes mais position pas simple du
tout à tenir surtout et si peu de temps
la pendule je trouve donc faux seins
quand on attaque le cavalier c'est cet
art outre une destination peut advenir
en d5 pour rebondir là ou là un moment
et faire pression sur sur châssis savoir
dans quel système joué tour à huîtres
oppose échange de cette tour sur le 8e
tour assad peut être tour à sept alors
voilà kg 5 peuvent apprendre parce que
fourchette rouge et cette blonde un peu
la pression autour du roi ok bon pour
l'instant ça tient pour les noirs si
juste post 1 tu as joué il a pas
beaucoup de temps mais le fou à revenir
vers des quatre peut-être un moment bon
pour l'instant prem's qui peut pas
bouger parce qu'il ya le matelas 20 mai
c'est ce qu'il aimerait arriver à faire
un truc comme ça à venir mettre la
pression ici mais bon dur à faire mais
les blancs du cac faut trouver qu'on
progresse et c'est parfait non plus ça
peut se jouer à la pendule à la souris
tout simple
tu auras de tomber 2 pourquoi pas bien
aux échanges des tours où la nature en
l'air en baisse est la gaffe et ben non
ma fille ruth jallet qui craque vraiment
pas ce que ça doit jamais la perdre
évidemment et évite de ça commence à
faire vraiment lourd attention donc on
repart peut-être pour l estonienne à la
femme si tu dises fait danser système de
notation des chèques j'ai regardé le
film totalise pointing freeway si je
fais des chiffres et c'est punk king
seul pion du roi donc le pion est fluide
et accessoires 3 et manger nous serait
ou 3 le coup voilà bishop bishop five
basse et jean repoussé cinq housewives
cinq talibans tués voilà c'est ça ok
donc on repart sur cette famille où il a
joué à 4 à leur petit rac
la preuve qu'à three change de ligne
dominé le monde ça va ressembler très
floue 3 il partait pour du foie justice
de toute façon h5 joué par firoud déjà
peut-être rock on s'arrache 4 on peut
mettre le cas les 1 h 1 et rebondir vers
f2 ou quoi après ok donc il le passe
directe en f1 c'est pas idiot donc
il veut venir là en fait dans le nom
c'est ça l'idée des blancs 7 jeux pour
cette case ou g5 créé un peu le désordre
chez neuf sur f6 le truc c'est qu'on va
boucher la vue de ce fou et si la dame
bouge bien suivant elle vingt dix foyers
de pas mal de ce côté quand même on
évite le pion d'avancé donc fou g5 pas
mal cavalli et six retours bon ben je
peux jouer qui a lieu trois clubs
l'envoie là c'est le coup de choisi par
les vannes qui a l'air qu'elle a très
bien comme un coût d'accès 7 maintenant
donc peut-être que ce que cherchait déjà
c'est qu'il réagisse est ensuite très
bas sans le lent voilà fouache 4 je
pense et qui est une tour vite peut-être
il va être temps de faire un truc comme
à 5 kgs c4 un moment mais il a fait
d'abord f k rock et ça joue vite les
bonnes nouvelles races à l'aise dans ses
positions je veux dire il les enchaîne
bien assez vite il est bien jouer celle
de total en cinq minutes et dont on va
voir en tout cas les moeurs cam qui ne
l'oublions pas menace reprend ses trois
qui enlèverait de ce cavalier et de
prendre ensuite soutien aux quais ou
cinq joueurs donc je recommence avec
cette percée qui a été très fort tout à
l'heure et sur fion prend soin des six
soit f5
en tout cas ces thématiques et 2,5 avec
ce qu'eric honorer la f5 je vais pas
refaire hodja lui même met donc le 6 je
pense c'est logique mais non plus tard
mais maintenant peut-être ok bon il va
pas fait il défend un peu les pions
comme ça ouais ni d'excursions prend le
il veut pousser attaque la dame quand
adam bougies le reprendre mais c'est
encore difficile pour fil rouge à la
position il se fait complètement enfoncé
au centre faux et fuite mais il tente de
défendre
coli peut maintenant aussi ce sera
d'autant plus de bonnes conditions un
autre coup keller très bien c'est tout
ça c'est un cas qui sécurise le cavalier
voilà stone la case donc fou 17
peut-être bouger les foules à un moment
mais bon quoi qu'il en soit si tu as
peut-être affolant pour les blancs je
sais pas j'avais 6 ans
ça me plaît faux b5 je pense près de la
b3 mais non les trois il peut prendre
andré prendre c'est quand même la menace
des normes maintenant
kébé 6 bien jouer les normes vont pas
devoir tout prendre parce qu'après à la
fin il a bougé 3 avec une enfilade avec
la dame et la turquie ont entraîné donc
pour l'instant le pion est toujours
défendu de manière tactique est la
variante l'audi de tête
pion un pion prend comprend tout reprend
pour prend dame prend fou la tap la dame
tap la tour dont vous êtes re met une
pression là-dessus ces règlements et
fuite ils défendent et lui maintenant
ils leur place de ce côté mieux placé
est donc finalement aux six un moment
donc les draps manque d' espace mais le
fou autre forme à venir ici car deux
trois trucs avaler ce qui se replacent
mon parent menace tour à trois jouées
par leeuwen intéressant mieux être juste
un truc comme h3 sur qui on prend
prendre ici et coulisses et là bas c'est
ok kerry h5 on prend vaguement pions f4
libère le fou un g7 fèves de bons à
rabat vous qui faisait plus trop grand
chose défend la case est aussi un truc
les gens aiment bien faire si peu des
fois c'est pousser b4 domjan structure
pour arriver vers le jeu elle dame
notamment la colonne c'est qu'ils
seraient une bonne colonne pour eux
puisque le kayamb et 6 en fait tu prends
la casse ces huit donc ya pas de tours
qui vont venir là donc si jamais on
échange ses pions up les blancs ou
pouvoir envahir les noirs se rassurent
la colonne s'est donc c'est un plan à
prendre en considération pour l'instant
pas possible bien sûr b4 il ya juste si
on prend et on se prend une fourchette
mais bon sang on peut travailler dessus
faire tomber un match comme ça là bas
c'est ça peut être bien pour les blancs
quoi faut acheter ce dont quatre avec le
plan efficace donc soit g3 sauf au 3g
mais jean pet food roi ça évite
d'affaiblir un peu plus la plus loin g3
qui habite pas grand chose at on me
dirait mais maintenant l'autre je pense
les veines qui marque une petite pause
pour se décider il a fait donc
d'ailleurs j'ai 3 défendant son pion
cavale il revient sur m6 est tombée
trois man dangereux ok donc il veut
juste chassés sous les 5 très très
ennuyant et sa cape town le déferrement
attend qu'il va pouvoir prendre après
pour voir s'il y avait quatre c'est un
truc muche poursuivre cette fiscalité
dessus éprouvé 5 comprend le 5 30 et 5
4,34 à mon avis c'est ce que veut faire
les bonnes s'avère logique en bottes
bintou reprend et d'un mode je pense
inquiets 6-4 ok pourquoi pas ma foi non
c'est très bien absent fait de la
qualité de moins elle n'est pas si grave
si par contre que la nouvelle pour les
tournois et du coup dur s'activer quoi
donc c'est pas grave c'est comme ça
qu'est le 3e tour doit partir ou encore
projet cat faire trois pions pour la
qualité est encore une démonstration je
vais redevenir attention la tourbe et
s'inquiétait quai mais bon pour
l'instant il n'a pas fait de guerre
encore les vannes dans le match il peut
prendre des 6 ou g4 ou g5 un jour
peut-être on verra fou un peut-être
maintenant pour défendre l'option à 5
non il rate son cavalli très bien 2005
ça s'accélère à fond dames à 4 et e7 qui
avance à cette terrible il y aura retour
trompions et vous serez à lire partout
quoi
cela même du d'âme des uns c'est pas
très grave il peut juste couvrir comme
il a envie en fait voilà l armée la dame
toutes les protections c'est très très
harmonieux la position j'aime beaucoup
et ses deux pions qui font très mal
huit déjà cinq ou 17,5 ou je ne sais pas
quand il veut
les échecs roi et peut-être justice est
d'ailleurs je n'aime pas de menaces des
noirs en fait 4 qui est des sept qui
arrive qui est peut-être fouquereuil
trois d'entre eux trois dames d'achat
qu'au hockey
bon bien sûr on peut apprendre cette
tour puisque il ya lui on est en arrière
mais ça me prend les six bien jeu de la
part de l'even qui a carrément ma télé
noir et nouvelle victoire 9 de 9 2 pour
les bonnes qui je pense que là c'est
vraiment un avantage décisif déjà vu
rouge après une leçon comme et simple at
c'est vrai mais t'avais pas sous-estimer
les bonnes on aime bien les petits
jeunots quoi mais faut pas oublier tout
ce que les autres ont fait toute leur
carrière et les vanités de 1830 c'est
par un coin après fear ou doit il va
arriver petit à petit un faux lui s'il
prend bien sûr et voilà
mais belle domination l'attend sidérante
de vivonne j'ai bien aimé comment il a
joué
alors on est reparti sur une petite
espagnole encore donc cette variante
détroit finalement ça fait trois fois
qu'on le voit et des bornes ce retour
est bien calé en b sat pas terrible
peut-être il n'a pas trop d'avenir mais
bon si un jour il fait des cinq qui est
des cissé revient en jeu ou alors il va
la ramener en des huit aussi ça c'est
bien sûr de l'autre option c'est que je
puisse partir par là donc alentours vite
jouée fou ou trois bons peut-être suite
voilà regroupement pièce assez classique
de l'aborder noir je pense que furent
hodja va tenter de jouer à 4 à un moment
s'ouvrir la colonne à et dévoiler un peu
plus sur ce tales d'âme quand même à 4,9
et finalement par ferrou déjà prises ces
quatre prises c4
il est bon d un don fait aux jo qui se
place sur la colonne ouverte essayé de
me disent de pions arrière et là bas
mais bon ça c'est celui d'un homme pour
les 22 pensent position à avoir commencé
à tourner et qui a été de en tout cas
joué par ferroudja donc qui va replacer
ce qui allait vers la halle d'habitants
vont faire ces 5 et rebondir par ici
aussi donc coup multifonctions quelque
part qui a aidé vite sa combativité pas
grand chose aura peut-être on a enlevé
cette dame est le cavalier l'a essayé de
venir ici peut-être un jour d'amis de
jouer d'ailleurs voilà donc libère la
case de 6 pour le cavaliere b cinq
finales manquées assez logique aussi
pour en l'espion et que les blancs à
cette pièce là donc chacun son truc
alors là je suis il inaugure un coeur
c'est un jour que vexé 5
car on lâche on lâche la quasi siméon
gensel l'a donc à voir en tout cas les
vonn qui a laissé furent jazz créatures
passé
b pour s'activer mais je serais pas
surpris s'il ya une pollution que soit
mieux pour les blancs tout ça
parce que bâle qui ont passé baisser
quand même quelque chose quoi donc aller
fin il revient peut défendre son roi et
donc je pense les vannes doit on peut
jouer son va-tout sur les droits envoyer
du jeu là-bas peut-être qu'ils voyagent
5 maintenant préparant des f-5 décalé il
ya des choses comme ça en tout cas ces
cinq faits établis sont qui est des
quatre g6 hockey prend les cases et il
va peut-être préparer dû être 5 un
moment et des cinq joueurs donc sur qui
les cinq c'est une bonne case en plus il
veut faire casser ça t elle a embêté
espions donc donc voilà il est mieux il
est mûr il est mieux peut-être qu'à
value8 du coup à jouer pour pour les
vannes se tient la case s'est pas encore
perdant sur les dames et bombay ci est
au système une menace mais c'est quand
même plein de problèmes à tour bessette
a été joué peut-être qu'ici ça dit vous
sacrifiez simplement la qualité une fois
de plus qu'on la partie d'avant veut pas
eu d'avancée l'a vraiment fort là c'est
vraiment juste forcé et ça semblait être
quand même bien pour les blancs petit
après prise prise prise nature à tour b6
quand même qu'ils rentrent attaque et
attaquera le pion l'a fait des trucs
super des six donc ça leur salaire pas
moi qui sait cette crème je n'y ai
d'ailleurs il l'a joué donc je pense
qu'il faut s'inquiéter la qualité et on
va voir tomber si ça arrivait ensuite un
ok c'est ça sent les deux défenses pas
laisser tomber c'est gratuit bon il peut
au 15e tour b 6 soit dit en passant ne
seront pas mal tomber pour le blanc bon
qui permettra d'en rentrer à tour
pouvoir doubler les tours en cas de
prise sur qu'on a dû pions et on voit là
il a fait et il va peut-être gagner je
pension du retour des biens maintenant
peut-être très bien c'est juste logique
et ben on va s'accrocher on l'a vu une
quantité pas très bien il arrive à
défendre à fond et c'est ce qui est en
train de faire il accélère la cadence
d'ailleurs avec son cahier satour saddam
y prend les cases d'entrer ici et ils
tentent de contrôler autre côté je pense
f5 va partir peut-être dès maintenant
d'ailleurs mais ça n'empêche pas que la
pression n'est pas très plaisante pour
les vannes et 6,6 ok bon il va tenter de
leur faire un blocage ici c'est déjà
quelque chose d'important pas les
segments s'engouffrer dans la colonne
ouverte
c'est un bon coup je pense bon juste le
problème c'est que lui silva sera menée
ici aussi sûrement dès maintenant
d'ailleurs je pense un bon bout qui est
des cinq pour les blancs et et qu'ils
peuvent encore il fait tomber trois 3
sets joués
alors peut-être trois sets c'est avec
l'intention de se débarrasser de ce
mauvais fou c'est pas non plus un truc à
oublier parce que c'est là que se fout
ils firent rien schena après lara pu
avoir peut-être un avenir bricmont par
ici mais bon donc fou si un jour et par
fille ruth jacky veut peut être à
l'écart à 3 déjà refusé les changes du
fou est aussi dégager ce cavalier de la
qui est si jeune oncle ouais je
m'attends à foix iii peut-être pour les
blancs rouges et 5 bons d'autres objets
ce cavalier
mais bon toujours est il que à rognan
arrive encore à pas rendre la tâche
difficile à son adversaire c'est quand
même pas facile de ne jamais avoir une
victoire comme ça
bon cela dit ça doit gagner on va voir
comment
si je joue et je pense qu'il va tenter
de ramener le fou pour colmater là bas
est ce qu'avec les blancs il va vouloir
jouer ça en fait je pense est rentrée
mais on reprend je pense dame b 2 voilà
où d'am-dam b2 et doit rentrer sur 17 et
un moment ça va être décisif tout ça est
ce inquiétant bessette sûrement voilà
bon faut rien faire mais bon tu devrais
faire c'est juste prix aux prises
d'hamelin est le même sur dame prend ici
un de calvi en mer donc ouais non ce qui
est même tombé systèmes sont ici bon ok
il n'a pas fait tout de suite c'est
juste un communiqué ils regardent un b
sat a7 a6 marche 1,6 à cet adam et les
vendeurs étaient quelques échecs
mêleront achat va être très bien caché
donc on peut faire insiste je pense
trois boudin prendront h1 et ce cavalier
trop loin dans les vergers 3 suis pas à
tenter des trucs comme ça mais juste ça
marche on va prendre fin la parade je
sais pas donc il reprend cela
et empreint de hauteur de 4,6 mais
manquait juste même damas fuite qui
arrivent et leurs avoirs thirsk damage
suite de me promener seins qui suit pas
de prendre la tête
il ya plus de pièces pour les membres
attaqués d'un match quatre quidams à
dieu ouais ok mon victoire 2 0 de jacky
je sais pas comment il a eu deux
défaites d'affilée et finalement ça peut
être dû faire du bien au moral de
l'enfant gagner une
donc nouvelle anglaise evans qui insiste
dessus et beaucoup t il a plutôt raison
je pense c'est celui apporté un bonheur
pour l'instant ce choix d'ouverture et
donc granby dame classique avec faut
être quatre ou cinquième couteau jour
est donc cette variante l'a donc dans
laquelle ces notions assez fermée et
dans laquelle les noirs vont tenter
ensuite de casser les pions blancs avec
des 6 à 5
fondée si cela doit être plus ou moins
logique avant qu'il ya un souci mais bon
il ya celle sur un chanteur mais b6 et
de oui bon c'est le bouquin on veut le
faire pour se donner un peu d espace et
respirer parce que le fou est très
mauvaise dans un b6 c'est logique sur b4
ont fait à 5 par an pia à 3 après pour
défendre la chaîne de pions mais ça va
donner l'option d'une fois ci soit noir
donc de se débarrasser de sauver food
ramallah touré fuite vers beldame star
ac c'est un juste ya un truc à
surveiller bien sûr tout le temps c'est
ça parce que ses positions passées mais
sinon sinon ça va prendre en général
c'est assez solides comme comme idée en
tout cas les bonnes qu'à raison de pas
prendre une ligne trop risqué un truc où
il peut presser gentiment est assez
fermé on qu'il a hésité un peu
joue trop tactique la confrontation trop
direct donc quelque part logique de
faire tout ça alors b5
finalement je vais maintenant on va voir
partir les n'auront toujours pas
solutionné le problème de l'heure de
leur fou de cases blanches par contre
donc fuir au jack qui ont ces arrivées
le long de la colonne à et qui
s'infiltrent bon c c'est juste ça rien
de décidé bien sûr parce que les blancs
ont un peu la pression son contrôle et
je rappelle le problème principal des
narcisses ce fou qui fait rien mais ce
sera un problème constant quand même
dans 30 contre on se parle et il n'y
aura pas on l'activé donc pour l'instant
il tient les pions ça va mais pas ce
truc que avec pluies ou quoi peut être
est ce aussi un autre plan pour le lot
de transférer ce qu'elles valent divers
là cinq jeux va encaisser un qui
émettront un peu il ya ba ça améliore un
peu les choses fois g5 pas mal joué même
bien jouer j'aime bien visible set et
j'ai ici c'est une concession que faire
des sacrifices de super date ils vont
marcher très vite je sais pas mais ça
peut arriver là faut déjà regarder de
près cette île de me prendre 7 k -o 5
après faut voir ce qui se passe sur g61
qui est 5 faire damer vite sûrement
poitiers sacrifice obligé ok ça va mais
il va à bouger son fou peut-être ici et
là et avoir ça qui va arriver
mais ça va c'est pas mal cadenassé mais
il faut faire attention avec les noirs
en fait c'est une proposition je
préférerais avoir côté blanc bons tours
b troquet vieux un peu réduire la
pression long de la colonne à 5 jouer
maintenant par firoud déjà bon le bon pu
bloquer avec h4 s'ils veulent mais je
suis pas sûr soit très important je
soude et 3 voilà bien placé pour premier
3,2 me prendre les 3 pour un 4
peut-être donc il faut ces deux dames à
8 ce peut-être
mais il faut regarder d'amd 3 6 1 d'un
petit roy blessé un autre attaque la
tour en tout cas est d'amener 3 les
masses avec ce genre d'idée peut-être en
tout cas il a bien fermé la maison sur
la colonne a pas de cas se fait t as pas
de case donc ça y est de se faire
envahir et peut-être que petit à petit
peut avoir une idée de ramener le roi là
bas a bien joué damas quatre profite du
cloître incendie défend et donc
peut-être l'arrivée durant et à voir
s'il peut après essayer de débloquer
tout ça mais c'est donc très ferme
événements comme position il peut ne
rien se passer aussi un je ne sais pas
mais les blancs on peut aussi à tout le
monde décidé de prendre un peu d espace
là bas âge 3g 4 ça me semble pas
mauvaise voilà c'est ce que fait les
bonnes prises prise
ce qui n'empêchera pas peut-être de
mètres après le pion ici de vouloir
envahir la pas la colonne
dames 6-3 dommage 3 un truc c voilà
c'est toujours pas fini je ferais bien
du g5 j'aurais dit mais il ya peut-être
fou cran parce qu'on aura plus haut prix
comme ça tu en prends comme ça c'est
moins bien donc dems est inquiet je
comprends il veut faire g5 et qu'en cas
de prise et puis se reprendre et que le
pion soient bien gardées par l'adam
dames 8 bon tir et que j'ai cinq ça va
ou dames 3 et d'un match 3 pouces et 2
même mis ton tour à 2 alors quand il
manoeuvre mais clairement l'intention
des blancs c'est de ramener madame petit
à petit ou de les sacrifier un truc sa
patte tout simple à gérer pour les
marches trouve un hibou très vite la
main mais ça peut c'est peut être un
problème
ja retour h3 peut-être comme semble
défense on libère la dame du secteur
défensive
voilà où je vais parler van hille adam
peut ramener du coup même si pas des
deux de 2003 2003 d'un match 4 ou damage
par la life 5 hockey très concret très
directe comme approche
mais c'est intéressant je vous le faire
bon ben là bas bon cela dit je sais pas
si c'est pas bon en flammes et côté
blancpain manager sait plus trop ce
contrôle ça marche ça marche pas à quoi
il a bien préparé son truc en tout cas
mes salaires ça a l'air pas mal surtout
en conseil veut faire d'am dam des huit
faux et fuite il y aura toujours kenny
satoca ou rappelé le foot élite sera
cloué donc c'est un problème si tu
reprends d'un mais chaque foule a forcé
snia matecki et 17 non de la fois
défendre comme ça c'est la menace dit
blanc food et ses attaques et défend la
huitième rang j'ai maintenant peut-être
qu'il prend 9 7
je sais pas si ça marche mais c'est déjà
un coût qui peut donner envie même qu'il
prend 17 pourquoi pas en fait parce que
il va vouloir prendre ça il ya pas qu à
l'ifsi ça près
quelque chose comme ça ou f6 les dollars
très fort qui avait six ou pions f6
damas deux jardins et ses quatre
éléphants
ces firmes ont foutu damage quatre
grands défunt f2 à ce dommage cette
baisse je pense qu'avant non ici bien
manoeuvré les vannes encore un jeu c'est
pas ça devait se tenir peut-être mais à
un moment il arrivait à venir en force à
l'est le roi est il à terme d'un match 4
je pense qu'il y avait quatre c'est bien
aussi mme ashton beliet défunt f2 et et
voilà quoi eh bien je les bonnes donc
qui reprend ses 7 points d'avance
j'étais son avance maximum jusqu'à
présent et écouter bail pour sa maîtrise
bien le match donc toujours les petits
espagnols et joy ride avec des quatre
vous prend 1,2 tout reprend 1,2 qu'evra
ne prendre et c4 après donc c'est la
même partie même ouverture que la partie
précédente
donc les bonnes va sûrement essayer
d'améliorer un peu ce qu'il veut quand
même souffert et d'ailleurs il change il
envoie ses cinq années et est plus
conservateur avec ses 6 tout à l'heure
et la dire un qui vient la confrontation
et les pions ou g5 jouer donc par ferro
déjà qui a visiblement envie d'échanger
son four où le cavalier c'est assez
logique puisque la faiblesse est ici et
ils ont livré un des protecteurs de la
case des 5
donc ils veulent échanger avec ceux qui
allaient viennent sur des cinq donc
donc voilà alors le score ouais ça
faisait de la tête des joueurs montrent
avec la souris à une tête d'un rognant
avec un petit 10 de feu rouge avec un
petit 3 donc c'est le score du match
pour l'instant 10 à 3,1 pour pour les
pour pour les vannes
fabien sait si evans et femmes en bullet
alors je dirais pas qu'il faut grimper
nettement mais elle a une telle avance
avec ses 7 points que normalement c'est
bien suffisant pour lui quoi mais on
verra on verra bien on en est pas encore
là ce qui était le chrono je veux bien
je suis preneur m'intéresse tout ça donc
qu il dit
donc les bonnes qui masque a et b sa
tournée avant qui était pas terrible il
va leur amener là où la et direction des
4 potentiellement 20 - sur des cases
plus active mais ouais potentiellement
fait ce qu'elle dit quand même fort que
ce chou donc jean position où je dirais
préféré sur le papier pour les noirs
après faut voir concrètement comment ça
se passe toujours la même chose mais
vraiment c'est on est content et clément
d'art obtenu un petit quelque chose
comme ça a peut-être un coup comme à 4
une fois de plus ça peut partir
j'arrivais c'est que si nous en
apprendrons prendra suis là je suis là
prend une option à 4 en premier train à
5 mai dont chioggia qui a pris ici donc
je sais pas de quoi on prend les bonnes
de la tour ok mais bien peut-être à 4 je
me répète mais vu qu'ils aient un
clouage on craint pas les découvertes
je comprends marche pas à 4 des quatre
prêtres l'idée monfreid à 5,40 et faire
fixer n'ya pas ok vont tomber un parent
sur autre chose
bon prêteront le site tourbier 8 ou qui
sait si 6,6 au moins comme ça on va
pouvoir prendre ces quatre peut-être
juste prendre mes 5 du couteau reprend à
peu près mon la dame peut bouger à voir
oui je dirais que ça doit les points
noirs
ok d'amd un bon parce que prise sa prise
prix
c'est quoi l'idée pas juste prendre
bizarre mais bon petit veux juste ça y
est ça la dame qui arrive esfandiar se
débarrasse du trou du trou c'est pas
bête
ça évite que le voir ce cavalier venir
se planter avec cinq armes en attendant
ça on contrôle le dessin j'aurais pensé
à une tour qui prendrait et je sais pas
quand il veut et puis on prend kiev cap
maintenant et et qui est des quatre
sûrement pour bien tenir la case damage
qu'est ce qui a vraiment d'émanations
droit je suis pas sûr parce que dams et
syncopée endroit là voilà ça doit aller
au pian ahmed adam l'a donc aidé à l'eau
si c'est pas mal c'est bien ce qui
coulisse il il protège les cases donc
bondam g53 par là h3 été gelées et
peut-être donc on va pouvoir faire du
contrôle direct pour ces deux au tour
ces trois à voir qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire quelque 6 j'aime bien aussi
comme ça ils compteront plus que les
cases ça c'est la dame c'est une pion à
l'âme aussi d'ailleurs il est celui-là
contrôle ici donc pour l'instant on
s'est penché hier sur la colonne j'ai
alors il faut voir si la tour besoin
participé aussi à la fête avec un coup
comme f4 ou tour à tour trois tours g3
qui peut être une idée que j'aime bien
d'ailleurs tournant autour dire juste
pas choisir sa bonne colonne et il se
fait à l'heure où clift potentiellement
si ni les après new york on se lève on
ne va pas laisser faire il mettra sa
tour ici pour justement t1 les cases et
attaquer ce petit pion au passage
bon du coup peut-être tours 1 pour ces
trois je pense est qu'ils allaient f5 à
ce moment là une surprise puis on prend
comme ça la tour va passer par quatre
quand même on pourra pas tout tenir côté
noir donc toujours là ça me semblent
ardus en socket investissent a été fait
et ce qu'on a le temps de faire tourner
trois du coup je serais tenté de dire
oui mais ça te compliquer la position
story 3 tours c'est un roi ici dame
prend un f2 ok certains à cet échec mais
le roi valet par là on peut faire dame
prend l'échec de 1300 année et c'est
chaud parce que les noirs aussi menacé
les matins c'est double tranchant faut
bien calculer
bon il fait froid il fit ok bon on va
chez patou rejetteront peut
potentiellement cocumont ya eu 3 qui va
lire trois d'accord
peut-être qu'à ie6 tant pis on ne change
pas en reste aléatoire pas c'est mon
idée et blanc c'est que c'est légal et
s'échange sur la tour à venir ici et on
va consacre pression l'assurage 6 on est
bien placé donc ces lignes bon ok tour
ces deux biens 20 portes on peut pas
prendre bien sûr pas sur des preuves de
échec et mat donc chioggia qui adorent
mettre sa dame ici au moins c'est du
fond j'ai deux syndicats de la f4 ne pas
changer et d'inviter les problèmes
ouais au moins il s'en est sorti
clairement mon accent est sorti il à la
tour actif la seconde rangée il attaque
et f2 alors je sais pas s'il va gagner
mais il peut me faire du cahier la tour
c 3 1 mais un coup donc il peut-être
juste proposer une sorte de nuls mais
rangé trois tours du nom bon moi j'ai
trois heureux c'est tout avoir
sainte-croix caisse peut faire nul mais
ça peut peut-être joué c'est peut-être
tant pis à 6 mars à la fin mais c'est
peut-être la première minute du match je
crois je crois que ça provient d'une du
match après quatorze partis donc c'est
très animé
s'il ya une première nul alors fabre je
me demande si tu as la réponse à la
question de pourquoi à rognan est devenu
gm si tard à 18 ans il ya ainsi
redevenir si fort c'est le seul au tout
nouveau ouais alors bon déjà c'est une
génération
c'était moins facile à james ito cédé
moins de tournois - titrés en fait à
l'époque yvon paré mois les conditions
pour deuxième truc
peut-être que il s'était pas son
objectif qui cherchez pas trop aller
jouer en dehors de l'arménie je sais pas
c'est possible aussi à voir mais je veux
dire programme unique
je sais pas quel âge il est devenu grand
maître mais ce que c'était si tôt ça
reste à voir quoi mais bon faut pas et
précocité ça rime pas forcément avec
longévité et avec non plus atteindre le
sionisme auparavant qu'ils avaient
exemple de nigui le joueur le joueur
indien qui tient les mecs qui dans les
petits plus jeunes grands maîtres de
l'histoire mais qui la joue même plus
aux échecs quasiment ça peut se parer à
ce genre d'histoire donc on s'enflamme
souvent à dire oui je ne très fort et
votre champion du monde doit d'être une
carte s'est dit si ces machins bon cinq
minutes comme il faut voir bon qui sait
si ce petit rebond peut-être détroit à
venir pour casser un peu ce centre
bonjour toujours bien pour les nerfs des
réactions ici en fait parce que ça
limite le spot du fosdem des cases si el
khaliki rentrer oullins bon voilà par
son meilleur qu'elle 5 serait contre et
sur lequel prend le 4 mai un jour ou
l'autre il va bien falloir casser ce
option qui est gênant dont quatre vingts
minutes dans la session 3 + 1 et puis
après on en une demi-heure de bullet
pour finir tout ça
[Musique]
avec ce nom de ces cônes et attoub et 4
pour après leurs noces à tu parles dans
la catalane et doux mais qui vient
d'arriver sur le chat c'est lui à toi
[Musique]
mais ça lui est ouest où tu peux te
montrer en doses non tu veux l'intérêt
je peux pas bouger les pièces pour moi
je te ferai une autre fois je sais pas
pourquoi je peux bouger les pièces en
fait c'est juste chiant j'ai ce problème
ce sens mais en fait peut-être parce
qu'il met l'option de pronostics des
coûts et qui paie pas ce que tu veux
j'en sais rien donc c'est un peu bougé
depuis que j'étais parti donc le pion a
disparu j'ai bien fait des trois pour le
faire sauter mais pour l'instant ils
restent en plus par l'énorme pouvoir le
récupérer tout ou tard mais je pense les
blancs monts patronale ne serait ce
qu'avec une dame de tournai un moment
moi je sers guerdane des doit pas se
prendre du tour 2 mai mais ça va
oui oui grégoire du score c'est vraiment
simple donc et b5 en tout cas menace la
fourchette en c7
c'est pas mal joué tour de quand même
donc je semblais ce fou peut-être un
petit poucet 3 ou qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire d'autre qui est des six
intermédiaire j'ai pas pensé utile ou
prendre hockey ouais tu peux comprendre
et sûrement faire ça et ça après
peut-être qu'il a le temps à nouveau une
potion pas simple mais bien placé cette
tour ici peut-être faut juste la chasse
est en fait jusqu'à ce qu'elle est si
pénible est allé voir ce que ce que font
les noirs après tour main occulte un peu
le même genre d'idée on veut dégager
cette tour d'ici où elle est très bien
passé donc sur la seconde rangée dans le
prochain coup si les vannes peut il va
juste prendre et on voit que ce cas
libyen place et enfin parce qu'il
n'interdirait sua de venir ici ce qui
est quand même pas mal du tout donc 4 à
6 pour 2009 et 5 du coup voilà joué par
fille ruth jardon cavaliers maintenant
soit qui et c'est cette envie de
rebondir ici soit qu'il y ait des six
mais plutôt qu'elle c'est ça ta première
de voile attaque la tour ensuite il va
prendre la 2 fois les noirs proche de
cai ici bougera saddam mais ça a l'air
un peu mieux pour les blancs ont une
fois de plus on tarde la structure aussi
j'aime mieux ces pièces avec les plans
et avance à la pendule considérable puis
30 secondes pour phil rogers partie
contre une attention on apprend à la
tour de vis donc je pense
je pense c'est pareil c'est vrai que
c'est sans cela en fait au moins n'a pas
rendu le pion des peut-être d'un v8 3 g7
qui a aidé 5-fu 4 ok bon au moins sa
récréation des sera que ces pratiques
aient bien joué
et ensuite ils vont envahir les noirs
sur les métiers manger quoi c'est ça
l'idée mais sûrement alors peut-être
qu'il y ait des cinq quand même ici
menace un truc sur m6 par un idiot alors
qu'il ya eu ce genre d'idée dames 6 3 à
suivre c'est bien utile hitléro l'esat
donc ok c'est pas mal quand même non
et maintenant ils mangent le pion qui
avait trois fours shot ou de la bombe a
du coup on va se battre et gundam 2 mois
mais bon là il y avait cinq ou vingt de
jeu et ça peut le faire alors quand même
san storage f5100 plus faire jusqu'à
face à peut-être dans les fuites on perd
qu'une qualité mais c'est quand même
bien mis à part et si bon c'est pas
encore gagné en fait c'est assez marrant
kelly price is sûrement moi j'essaie
trois fuites orages et saturn ses
proches c'est tout qui avait en jeu
avait retrouvé cet onguent 7 4 des 5
c'est bien pour les noirs c'est évident
mais ok tu peux t'attendre à mieux quoi
tu ta ka myéline dames et finale avec
une qualité de plus
je prends logique des 5 fu des trois
tours si vite peut-être quoi à 5 e faire
à 4 c'est bien joué
ivan levai le socle la défense des noirs
dans les vagues initiale de viol un
niveau voici deux pions c et d et ça va
avancer assez vite derrière je pense
qu'on peut prendre et praxer trajet 7
ça défend un peu tout mais bon ça bouge
pas que les pions cd bronze
mais bon logique aragon qui se bat comme
il peut dans cette position difficile
il n'y a pas de raison de finir vite il
est en avance à la pendule donc qui joue
sa chance à fond cas ici dans ses
dernières bloqués sur des quatre est
bloquée comme il peut sur les kasmas
écoutez c'est pas c'est pas mal joli
tout ça cette g51 gens poussés devant
les piètres 5 puis je sais pas tu sais
pas si claire f 5,6
franchement est ce qu'ils pouvaient être
cinq fois aussi ce cas là pourquoi pas
tacle à tour vous faire cailler des 6e
tour repeint romontois mais c'est plus
simple maintenant franchement c'est très
compliqué la position trois des quatre
qui est arrivé peut-être c'est
franchement tout peut arriver maintenant
je sais plus quoi comme 6 kg qui pousse
au lieu de sacrifier pas grave
pourquoi des deux rendez vous du coup
bon sa finale
à proposer nul n'a pas été acceptée
juste par manque de temps
ok des trois quilles du stand nul
eh bien écoutez quelques sauvetages à
rognan il est un ressort encore en
défense c'était quelque chose quoi eh
ben ça ça peut vraiment mettre m sur joe
fond du trou quoi mais ça lui arrive
juristes qui arrive dans le chat ne
trouve pas mal rennes en frappant grosse
défense pour gignac 15 gains possibles
même mais il s'est pas affolé il a bien
alors combien de partis en face ajoute
bompard tissage ou en temps louis da don
qui doit rester une petite dizaine de
minutes je pense cette cadence va
prendre à une demi-heure de bullet et ça
sera terminé quoi ouais défense de
bouffer la même file a gagné quoi c'est
ça qui est juste dingue fantastique
donc on revient d'une position très
similaire à la partie d'avant et ses
couleurs là
sao similaire il ya encore voir jouer
sur la case des zincs mais est-ce que
c'est suffisant pour vraiment prétendre
al'avantage dur à dire
2006 propose les changes des dames
problème des blancs c'est qu'une fois
qu'il aura changé plus on prend l on
serait que le pied c'est trop attaquer
et l'option v4 donc on va être obligé de
cavalia 2 assez moche quoi enfin pas
trop ce qu'on veut faire
du coup quoi d'autre dans mes deux
possibilités qui a aidé 5
c'est un peu tôt et possiblement hockey
dame b2 choisit donc par par partir au
jo puis on prend mes quatre simplifie ce
qui se passe sur ce talent dam leca libé
saad qui était pas terrible va pouvoir
se réactiver sur ces cinq donc assez
logique direction des 3 peut-être
et voilà
ouais mais bon je pense que ça va très
bien présent pas de là dire qu'il
avantage mais juste ça va quoi les
blancs occuper ces deux cases mais le
fouille opérée hier à la barre et puis
je pense ça doit les jeux pour étonner
qui pousse un pion il fait un truc dames
8 propos de l' échange donc des dames
toujours mais évite les dames 6 6 les
coups comme ça
bien sûr d'un v6 peut-être juste d'un
billet vite votre logique de jeu comme
ça pour les vannes et de rentrer dans sa
petite finale tranquille
ok donc maintenant baffes et je vais
essayer de l'embêter des 25 est blanche
mais tu auras trois peut-être qu'il va
arriver ici at-elle des 3 is ok on va te
refaire calvin un coup passif comme ça
ça va pas vraiment donné l'impression
que les longs jours pour le dire mais
dessus je pense les noirs auront juste
ramener le roi par ici ou peut-être je
le fous angers 5 ans des huit avoir mes
sauts de plus ou moins équilibrés mais
par un problème pour allianz est partie
en tout cas donc toujours plus sets aux
scores pour pour leur avenir
si beaucoup et je sais pas ce que
prédisait le redis on y va en fait sur
sur les algorithmes match alors
tourbains h5 pas de maths du couloir
mais du coup des trois qu'on défend
l'ouverture b6 peut-être perdre des
trois contes des six ou dix je sais pas
ok étonnant je vais te dire comme choix
mais on verra peut-être c'était si grave
en fait qu'on calvin s'il suffisait pas
à défendre et vous des huit fois cinq
hommes blancs et qui s'est dit qu'il
devait jouer le contre je mets en tout
cas du coup les jeunes qui a toutes ses
chances pour l'emporter avec en plus
deux minutes contre 30 secondes mais bon
je vois tout s'affoler méfie rouge à la
fin il est si le temps d'arriver il a 16
ans je veux dire c'est pas non plus le
champion du monde demain il ne sera
peut-être un jour mettaient donc dix ans
ou je sais pas quoi rognant scamaroni en
quoi
kébé 3 j'aime bien j'aime beaucoup ce
coup qui en fait dominator pas de
colonne ici pas de colonne ici pas là
non plus j'aime bien un joueur bougera
2b 3 mais pour l'instant il fait le taf
sap avait des murs et d'autres pièces
constants ainsi qu'il prend des six
points 9-3 look et il s'en va mais bon
ça quand même pas 2 6 1 prenant de
l'avancé dans la position même peut-être
qu'ils aient b3 quand même métro le
prime sur tf1 qui veut prendre ici si
avec le noir on avait le temps en fait
de faire le roi qui bouge ça aurait été
sympa mais n'est pas si simple
peut-être que ça va juste tendre un nul
total il est donc s'arrêter bien jouer
la partie rouge à cette simplification
finalement pour l'activité alors qu'ils
me demanderais bien sûr donc salut à toi
félix qui sait pas si la garde
il joue aux échecs félix alors donc
l'avant dans la partie avant la pause 10
louga hockey très sûrement une moue
bottes qui vous invite à ses membres
diamant sur czech comme ouais si jamais
ça vous intéresse évidemment il ya plein
de leçons de choses comme ça c'est pas
mal fait et là j'aime bien le nouveau
truc qu'ils ont mis en place de ce
sprint afin de peser lourd roche en
déficit par m c'est à dire que on défie
quelqu'un faire plus que l'autre donc ça
c'est cool tu auras ça devient jour
devrait faire rage et cissé qui avait
lieu cette fourchette donc ok pour
maintenant peut défendre exception que
je pense moi j'essaie de leur âge ici ça
va être un coup quand même mais le peu
de faire très vite
facile un bon finalement ça se finira la
pendule encore une fois cette partie
36e prend 1,4
mais bon finalement ça tournait en
faveur de fuir ou déjà tout ça mais bon
c'est loin d'être gagné encore pour
autant parce qu'il ya très peu de
matériel restant sur l'échiquier
derrière les vonn qui prouve que des
changes des tours et attention au cloud
atlas enlever ce roi d'ys y voit la
cetra les embrouilles 5,4 quelque chose
comme ça qui est six maintenant s'ils
sont solides de faire un truc comme ça
ok si seconde compte quatre pour
l'instant les jeunes qui ont quitté les
premiers problèmes mais bon faut déjà
qu'ils tentent de mettre la pression de
l'opposition petite répétition par ci
par là méthode classique
c'est peut-être kf4 ok attaque g2 et g5
je sais pas où il peut aller partout
faut pas tomber mais il tombait je sais
pas s'il était déconnecté ou quoi mais
là je le voyais le temps qu'on sa fille
les fils et filles et fils et est ok et
comme dit philibert il manque des cours
en français
by claude ciment devant jean fera à
l'occasion on doit avoir pas mal de
vidéos qui arrive niveau plus débutants
on va dire mais voilà et
et ensuite ouais c'est peut-être prévu
que chose des séries pour prendre ce
site on verra comment ça se passe lors
de la victoire de pierrot déjà dans
cette partie score de 11 à 5
donc il n'y a plus que six points
d'écart je savoure sa reprend pas il
paraît qu'il reste une partie avant la
pause et d'ailleurs elle va reprendre
maintenant donc dernière partie de 3 + 1
après ailleurs à la pause et une
demi-heure de bullet pour finir donc on
verra comment ça se passe tout sa petite
anglaise
c'est reparti et donc à l'oignon qui
jouent des trois budget 3 cette fois ci
c'est lui à eagle qui est maintenant un
bonnet ici mais bonjour à toi et
bienvenue aux ouais si vous n'êtes pas
encore abonné à la chaîne c'est gratuit
pouvait le faire suite cliquer sur le
petit coeur juste au dessus là haut est
comme ça vous avez eu notification pour
tous les live notamment dès demain midi
on aura le match de maxime hodée partage
pour la troisième place médaille de
bronze à la coupe du monde
aussi on pourra suivre dingli rennes
contre radjabov pour savoir qui va
finalement gagné ce tournoi comme
intéressant aussi
et puis dans l'après midi on croit qu'on
s'a suivent le phisheur nomme chess les
quarts de finale de championnat du monde
quant à être sympa et ça sera vendredi
samedi dimanche voilà donc cette petite
anglaise ça ressemble un peu une sorte
de renfermer d'art sicilienne inversée
en venir à trois strophes ces
trois-quatre fois je crois qu'il va
arriver et des quatre là ont bien
logique les blancs qui commencent leur
jeu allèles dame qui avait eu 7 donc
replace le cas de l'autre côté et puis
peut-être joué un truc comme ça un
moment aussi
gfk des fois ça peut traîner bon pour
l'instant c'est pas le cas mais c'est le
genre de coup à regarder bon qu'en cas
d'avis si y'a pas de soucis mais c'est
la dame et ailleurs par la bombe est roi
où je sais pas à qui avec 4 vraiment un
coup parce que puis on prend les huit
dames j'ai quatre échecs et cavaliers
seront là donc on veut pas se balader
comme on avec la dame et ça semble
logique
lieven qui veulent en venir colmatée
direction la case des 5 mai ce qui va
voir le temps je sais pas j'étais pas
convaincu de cette prise en cas de jeudi
on va voir comment il se débrouille
parce que la fin si jamais un régal
d'avoir pu en arrière est comme ça c en
est content si on le court comme en
italie là haut mais par trop le passage
voire par bmg le fou remonter en c3
c'est très lent mais bon je pense qu'ils
doivent faire ce plan absolument pas ce
que c'est chiant sinon je veux parler
mais et bien voilà il se dirige vers des
cinq donc
mais bien sûr s'ils ne sont qu'un dessin
que ça change pas mal de choses sinon
rien faire de concrètement avant phares
f5 faire un truc parce que quelqu'un est
là ça est bien il y a près avoir faire
jeux sont fous en f4 lui même et c'est
donc ça va se jouer à ça en fait un jeu
de ils sont là divisés de la dame dont
qu'il évite quelques par f5
c'est une bonne mesure prophylactique
dans la position et great ou quoi c'est
juste après mais par contre je vais pas
le commenter regardez sur sur la chaîne
anglaise ou peu importe mais comme il y
avait déjà une nouvelle à midi j'avais
pensé que ça allait faire trop
d'événements de compter trois matches
dans la journée et puis surtout il ya un
truc beaucoup plus important que tout le
reste c'est c qui a quand même
s'interroge bourgain donc alors f5 joué
par par ferradj a bien joué donc y
réagit avant que john evans et eu le
temps de tout fixé dans la position et
donc il ya bien raison fait comme ça du
coup sûr h4 il va faire f4 donc prise au
cas c'est logique mais maintenant que
hyères iii peut arriver la tour e 8 pour
venir y fit enfin ouais c'est pas si
simple pour les blancs quoi cavaliers ou
4 d'accord
bon je sais pas s'il peut déjà des trucs
qui peut arriver
alors il a pris bon je crois du pion
première phase il prendre de la tour
donc moins stable mais évidemment permet
quand même plusieurs heures de jeu sur
celui-là pourquoi attaquer veut opter
pour ces deux types de défense latérale
sachant que sur wuala et ajuste dames la
tchèque qui peut de chiens donc tous
rêvent de à première vue faire rager un
gentil ça défend aussi saïd ahmed trois
échecs
c'est ça fait le taff aussi ce temps
tout est tenu à peu près chez les blancs
quand même et donc il sera menée ces
deux tours ici faire pression sur re5
mon style à faire tout ça ça peut aller
ça jusque là un peu peu fébrile
disposition durable en 4 h 5 qui
appartient à un moment nous avons
d'abord faut d'abord défendre le 5
alors est-ce qu'on peut pas prendre cinq
maintenant c'est quoi le souci c'est
qu'il ya peut-être tour et 8 tak tak et
quand le flou bouge tout reprend et
quand on prend sept tours lasseran prise
attaqué par la dame qui parle à tourner
donc moyen astucieux de défendre
fouetter un pardon ouais donc la banque
en main event
difficultés ainsi position je trouve
mais il va tenter de colmater ex taxés
alors là attention la menace c'est ça et
aussi des grands tours comme menace donc
il défend tout comme ça pour l'instant
mais dont cuir hodja qui envoie le pâté
sur le pur arrière et des blancs c'est
logique
arrivé à ce supplice qui est mis à jour
b5
ok bon l'idée j'imagine sur qui on prend
il veut lancer ses 4 mai à tant pis on
va j'ai envie de dire je crois qu'on a
obligé quand même d'accepter le le
challenge est en fait à quatre peut-être
ça va essayer de faire en nous mêmes aux
signatures passé là-bas à quelque chose
donc il choisit autres choses
différemment il fait ses gammes et c'est
bien jean vasseur et s'il me prend au
pain il peut prendre fin ce jeudi zoom
je sais pas comment faire bon désolé
j'ai quitté revenir parce que j'ai zoomé
comme un idiot donc
j'espère que le zoom est oubliée de ces
évents et on a réparé truc alors on a
réparé sans vraiment réparer je sais pas
pourquoi il n'y a pas la position
je suis désolé mais écoutez je m en
slide show peut-être
soit neutre non je passe à ok je
comprends le problème de ce monde ça va
marcher puisque je ferme suffit la porte
fenêtre
ok mais pourquoi pas bon ben j'ai perdu
l'échiquier cela dit on devrait l'avoir
je sais pas pourquoi
phil rogers qui a gagné la partie en
tout cas c'est la pause ça tombe bien
j'ai pourra tenter de réparer le truc
chevron paul pace l'échiquier en fait
juste c'est assez spécial
donc les jours
et
[Musique]
je suis de retour
et du coup je roche va réparer un peu
frais pour l'échiquier donc ça c'était
la fin de la partie précédente n'ai pas
pu tout à fait voir mais voilà est vrai
que si on va attendre l'arrivée des des
bullet ça devrait pas tarder je pense à
commencer donc moulin qui me convient le
chic et non c'est cool mais en fait je
sais pas je tends pelsy truc s'est
déréglé après bon mais là au moins j'ai
pu remettre le truc sur les règles à peu
près ça devrait marcher
bon alors qu'elle compose synthé de ce
soir contre wolfsburg
ça prend la pose quand même un truc
c'est assez intéressant quoi
bon ça fera la compo super
on va faire chez pas un petit coup de
l'équipe peut-être alors +51 rognant sur
le + 5 et 3 + 1 attend depuis cinq ans
j'ai sur un plus a dit cyril way écoute
on va voir dur à dire quoi mais la whey
il arriver à remonter un peu le score
fait aux jo et ses deux dernières
victoires ça laisse un suspense en
matière que cette c'était énorme même +5
je trouve ça va être dur mais bon une
annonce très rapide comme ça qui ça
donc donc on va voir comment ça se passe
c'est le start tard sa tech qui hélas ne
veut qu'ils aussi saluer vous les gars
mais n'annonce pas je vous lâcher
c'était pas prévu que je commente le
match d'après de de longue date en plus
je pensais que le match fut rogers
oignons début quand on m'a proposé à
l'être à 19h tu vas dont j'ai accepté
j'ai avec vous je pensais que le truc
après de great choc serait plus tard
dans la journée
mais bon il se trouve que c'est comme ça
et c'est très bien mais du coup je
verrais que plus ou moins deuxième mi
temps du match quoi donc quand même tu
vois déjà c'est un gros effort
d'ailleurs j'ai un petit oeil la sueur
sur le match à côté de moi trois minutes
de jeu 0 0 écoutons ce que ça va donner
il m'avait folle et kylie qui habite à
manger qui verra pas le bullet sinon on
mange dans une demi heure
bon je pense pas qu'il rudoie de voyage
mais bon je sais pas on sait pas on
pilote ça se trouve il est juste lit
passionnant et on y va s'écrouler
prennent de souris ou dur à dire ok ça à
reprendre virunga avec les blancs et au
cac
il ya combien et écoute il ya 11 6 pour
1 rognant dans wii est ok donc voyons
qui revient sur la berline nationalement
et stop et sept petits doigts règne
entre l'on va voir un peu ce bull est ce
que ça donne donc des 5 réactions
centrale très vite ça a déjà commencé
nom de team chat
ouais bah oui ça déjà bien commencé on a
déjà fait les deux tiers du match il a
écoute c'est c'est juste le bullet donc
la version finale avec une minute par
joueurs ont ça très vite et et voilà ok
tu manges en famille le soir quand on
prends ton smartphone avec toi tablons
ce pas très poli mais c'est quand même
pour la bonne cause quand un stream de
grande qualité
tu est tenu au courant de cette sainte
et si tu as des bulles est un peu de
tout quoi donc ferroudja qui doit gérer
un cas ces cinq attaques la dam dom 6,8
j'imagine qu'il va défendre à 6
d'après ansa français 5 aussi un beau
cela dit et f4 donc qui ouvre le fou g6
et en plus peut menacer
un petit f3 moment donc avoir tourné un
jouet par firouz ja est ce qu'on peut
faire un et les pièces pour essayer
d'appuyer sur f3 on va voir moi je suis
là des faits à 4 donc il faut voir un
peu le drame
d4 joué par leeuwen donc en 4 citrons
bay lors duquel des quatre qui va
arriver donc sa crise de pions pour
potentiellement ouvre sa position ou
salle arrange mais j'ai un fond que si
c'est pas bon position sur mais qui dit
vrai mais je préfère une fois voire
peut-être les blancs ici trop vite joué
par les 25 essaie de faire tourner ses
trois tours b 2 je pense à 5
je vais donc parti ridja maintenant b
trois oncles et pas du tout donc faux b1
torbey 5 bien jouer attaque le fouet le
pion fou à 3 est donc possible de
croquer le pion à l'option pion à 5
c'est fait donc non plus pour à rognan
on va voir si phil rogers trouve des
ressources notamment comme des cas
peut-être un moment qui pourrait voir un
peu le jeu il a plus que 12 secondes 22
ça peut faire la différence et rognant
qui sert revient sur la colonne des qui
a tapé détroit et d'un coup donc l'om a
les jeunes qui passent très bien pas
dans la position qui est à 5 des
champions pas de ces quatre accueils
trompions profitant du cloud âge
comme c'est un donc peut-être pour faire
ces quatre ans huit tours 2
bon ben je crois qu'on peut bouffer des
trois à prendre le 5
un échange un jour cette dame des 4 et
donc position très très difficile avait
pour les blancs qui prend 6,4 sûrement
qui va arriver non il l'a pas fait ces
trois dames prend 6,4 maintenant même
bien d'hommes dessin hockey et dur dur
dur pour les blancs quatre peut-être un
jour moi que ça va super vite
lyon il arrive perception de moins
et c'est le roi blanc qui se retrouve en
grand danger quand j'ai 3 a bien joué et
angers 3-1 ils m'ont engagé de la fait
tomber mais en plus soit puis on prend
dame prend il a fait un échec à
récupérer à tour donc à rognan qui
viennent la première et qui monte à +6
et qui continue avec l'anglais ne change
pas son ouverture
et donc voilà encore une autre variante
où il a joué que 3 cette fois ci est
sûrement donc soit des quatre à venir
donc encore quatre jours un peu le même
scénario ce centre un peu bloquée tu vas
faire sauter côté blanc un autre membre
est poussée le pion b pour mettre le fou
en mai deux joué sur sur la grande
diagonale maintenant voilà c'est ce
qu'il fait avec les vannes a vu que les
n'auront plus de cases noires c'est
hyper logique de faire ça et je veux sur
cette déveine et ensuite faire f 3 4
encore une fois dégagé le cavalier jfk
prise en passant j'ai prend roy chef
théâtre tour g1 et on charge à fond
c'est quelque part logique s'il fait
quelque chose comme ça fait 5 jouer
bombe à ce que l'effet 4 s'est pas déjà
leur pourquoi pas en fait je veux dire
j'ai pas le problème mais donc comme je
dis prendre 2 g m leroy l'abord h1 la
tour ici et direction g7 tout cas
affirment déjà qu'ils disent unis
perdent 5 avant que tous genres truc
arrive
grégoire qui croient plus pour firoud
après cette défaite
brawl coûte donc bien je ne sais pas
jusqu'à ce qu'elle ait g6 d'en croquer
et du coup le tandem dame flagrant des
venelles pas mal pour les veines g4 et
g4 et g5 et je sais pas ce que devient
ce cahier spécial vient de changer ça tu
crois que ça devienne une piètre on va
jouer ce que je veux les vins d'ici très
fort quoi j'ai quatre bons toujours très
fort j'ai 4 mai mais bon c'est facile
d'autant plus donc et h4 été joués
benjamines g5 ça ou bien on prend fou
depuis 3h 1 et on va colmater son roi et
ça va aller
tous rêvent de sûrement défends tout ça
et il s'est juste une pièce de plus quoi
chacun je pense tour g1 qui va arriver
après questroy on peut le prendre je
pense à ok on peut pas trop le prendre
espions transcrites kg 2 ça libérerait
la case bien plus payant extrait libre
et le cas libyen là dessus donc voix qui
ne peut pas le prendre mal tolérés mais
on en est pas de grosse menace pour
l'instant avec le cavaliere 3 est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'on peut jouer côté ben ali
prend quand même
ok il va aller va laisser la case de 4
bon ça va quand même temps là pour
l'instant c'est pas possible donc
l'épreuve 3 2 je sais très bien tour ici
aussi les fuites et j'espère qu'elle j 5
un vrai tour j'ai cinquième attaque la
dame damage 3 pas trop de menaces ou qui
n'a plus le temps répétant les cool
kelly qui vit à angers 5 la tête la tour
tour dix systèmes c4 attaqué cette fin
s'est défendu mais on vise f7 comprenait
deux tirs échangés prendre ces 5
voilà qui est fait ranger me tuerait
mètres du cordon souvenirs en 1 8 dames
suite quand même et damages 3 vient
coulis siéger autour d'un il va juste
redescendre sa tour et tout est bien
protégé surtout que la dame est défendu
par lequel j'ai cinq aussi et donc
sûrement vers une seconde victoire de
lehman
si grave panne en position l'âme après
kf3 ou qu'elle prend ça mais aussi quel
prince est soit dit il prend le matériel
adams et de aussi qui était possible de
faire qui allie h7
mais bon il a mené un set après moult
sûrement h qui a joué par les veines
voilà le dnc de la vue cette fois qui
apprendre le caillage 7b coûté 6 pas si
simple ghenima non mais ça sera quand
même un pion de plus dans cette finale
de dame donc c'est quand même quelque
chose avec un peu compassé h
le roi qui en alaska chez donc c'est
quand même pas simple pour les pour les
noirs mais bon c'est en tout cas moins
perdant que ce que ça a été mais vous
assurons prendre des six cachets leroy
pousser les pions de route et ça devrait
quand même ce mal tomber pour ferroudja
mais bon il se démène il tente et en
tout ce qu'il peut pour pour maintenir
l'équilibré mais ça va sûrement pas
finir à se mouvoir la carrière des
joueurs dont 17 ben je sais pas comment
on fait en fait donc je devais l'avoir
jetée automatiquement en effet les
manips avant mais du coup j'ai ce live
en dessous est bon et du coup je n'ai
pas en fait
donc désolé on sera peut-être plaisir
c'est pas un choix ma part peut-être
oued zem des trusts réunion des deux
mais c'est pas grave ce sens il va
tenter d'avancer ses pions b5 maintenant
et petit à petit avant c'est une partie
qui voudrait très longtemps en fait
parce que on est déjà 70 coups joués ils
prennent une secondes par coup donc ça
peut se peut continuer du dam des quatre
matches un petit à petit et c'est de
faire baisser puis gagny caspar casque
je pronostique réa victoire d'un rognant
fait même de tous puisque les nachi se
tromper un moment et puis c'est fini que
la moldavie but de synthèse
incroyable un repas septimo techology
diack qui viennent nous faire une petite
reprise de volée sur un centre repoussé
donc ça c'est quelque chose si sainté
bat wolfsburg un très beau bon toujours
le même scénario en tout cas le roi qui
se prend d échec à droite à gauche mais
le pion à l'est jusqu'à b6 avoir reculé
mettre la dame
il ya même du dmg trois dames c'est cet
outil serait possible à un moment mon
foot être remonté le roi passer devant
le pion ça se travaille au corps mais
bon c'est tout bénef pour un rognon j'ai
envie de dire ce scénario parce que
c'est une partie très lente
bon déjà te perdra pas un empire ifra
nul mais je pense qu'il aime la gagner
et le chrono tourne donc donc horrible
pour fille rogers en fait c'est mieux de
perdre vite que ça c'est déjà 101 coups
donc sans un coup c'est une seconde
parcours face et ses deux secondes
rejetée par coup joué donc ces jarres
déjà 200 secondes en plus donc trois
minutes de match qui sont passés et il a
quand même perdu plus le temps initial
de cinq minutes sur cette partie un
sixième de la cadence qui où les favoris
qui vient de passer
et donc là je pense être très dur pour
lui d' espérer revenir c'est plus 7
je souhaite c'est un énorme score pour
pour les jeunes gens plus se débrouille
très bien donc finalement ça a pas été
aux quatre jouer cette fois ci mais sur
deux rétine sur deux voix basse et on
nous envie d'accepter bon
la joie était de très courte durée à
saintes et je viens de voir que facebook
égalisait de tempo les gars mais donc
voit une petite position
ouais mon futur à 15,05 ici de chasse
escaliers m6 ouvrir des grenats les
foncé sur l'autre coauteur sa trousse et
si si si défendre un peu tôt destin et
puis ce prix sous ces cinq mois ça va
très vite un rognon en justice est
absolument pas distancer niveau tant par
là il à 15 secondes de retard en général
y tient très bien le shaq et c'est
important cette cadence quoi
l'ondam h 4 min bien viser un peu ce qui
peut se tramer la rage ça bien sûr
regarde le cavalier en plus du faux et
de la dame
leucate jouer donc peut-être pour faire
un peu de trois plus tard cavalli aussi
je veux pas refaire aux jo mais les
vannes qui sacrifie la qualité une fois
de plus pour s'activer
mais c'est bien joué je pense qu'il fait
c'est très bien joué cavalier ou 5
donc il veut peut-être venir souvent des
trois soit web en tout cas les contrôles
des cases importante aussi veut faire
cailler g6 à un moment pour enlever la
dame h4 qui en fait la défense enfin la
défenseuse la pièce qui défend f2 en
tout cas si on fait qu'il valait
l'alluré d'alger 3 à son art à l'autre
et olic entre la pornographie dans fear
hodja qui prend parti pour éliminer ce
fou qui était pénible direction f2 mais
bon avec deux voies comme sauter un
rachat qu'est ce qui se passe ce tour à
8 peut-être ouais c'est le coup joué par
leeuwen faut trois tacles adam dame
prend b2 peut-être non dame g3 je dirais
alors du coup même provient sûrement
juste fou des quatre qui serait un souci
pour après dame eux deux c'est peut-être
possible
donc l evam mcafee beaucoup quand même
sur ce coup je trouve dames 2 ok donc
plus qu'un pour faire de cette position
torrent accueille des 3 waouh qu'est ce
que c'est bon c'est ça en fait qu'il est
temps réfléchi d'emprunt de 34,7 1.89
prend l'un mais tourcoing 8 ans 8
donc il ya des 3 1 c'est intéressant
d'un psychiatre ça joue sur les cloches
de tous les côtés d'un printemps
prochain qu'elle prend 1 donc de retour
pour la dame faisait cinq attaques la
tour quand j'ai vu si on veut la sauver
cette très passif il y aura des six
faire entrer une position pour offrir au
delà du coc torse nu de cloud mais
décide quand même peut-être ou annie
quelque chose comme ça autour des 8 et
il veut faire cailler d'être au prochain
coup je pense qu'il va faire que d'être
dame 30 et 3 il veut reprendre au quai
d'orsay cet assassin missclick c'est sûr
il voulu faire tour c'est un je pense
est donc victoire de phil rogers donc
qui revient moins 6 parce qu'ils aiment
beaucoup moins 6 il doit rester plus ou
moins un quart d'heure et monte nouvelle
anglaise lors des quatre saisons on est
indienne qui a aidé cette date grandes
lignes d'accès de donc joué par par
neven qui va faire des petits voilà
jouer autour d un même x 3 ce jeu un peu
3,5 aussi la position qu'ils regardent
et la stabilité en fait mais pas évident
de l'attaqué des six dans l'articulation
parce qu'à chaque fois il faut enlever
le cahier de d4 et elles sont là sa
validité des cases au noir pour faire 5
ou des choses comme ça donc
en tout cas je semble pas mal tenté
opérations allaient l'a5 stabilise le
cas ici 500 qu'on se prenne des quatre
mêmes c'est un jouet
et ça lui à ronald mac bobby qui nous
vaut ici bienvenue à toi et merci donc
de rejoindre la chaîne
j'espère cette pierre à il ya plein de
stream prévu cette fin de semaine dès
demain vidéo est de retour puis demain
après midi samedi dimanche tout le week
end donc fois trois filles ont joué par
les vonn qui a peut-être tenté ensuite
d'envoyer un petit des cinq pour faire
pression sur ces six avec ce fou et sur
des six ex suis là donc ça peut être une
idée à un moment ou un autre faux 5
jouer en tout cas shasta dame qui repart
très loin alors cyrillique en 17 minutes
il a le temps d'en gagner six ou huit a
toujours le temps mais c'est vrai que tu
veux tu as vu la partie d'avant mais tu
vois ce que de cinq minutes une seule
partie donc ça ça va tout le temps durer
un petit moment quand même ce qui hélas
rénale king sur bitstream écoute je
crois pas parce que kiev
qui avait parti en russie donc lâcher
facilement encore dans l'avion s'il
arrivait ou quoi d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça en fait c'est pas lui qui faisait les
commentaires aujourd'hui mémoire il part
sur un peu des vacances en russie et
donc du coup j'assure j'assure l'intérim
quoi mais donc je pense pas qu'yves
affaires l'aréna king ce soir après il
va quand même faire des vidéos et des
choses comme ça sur sur bitstream il y
aura de youtube vous inquiétez pas mais
mais moi je pense pas que ce soit et de
stream crime bon en tout cas chez rogers
qui s'en tire pas mal dans cette partie
qui commence à gratter les pions crée
des problèmes ni qui ni normal ans à la
pendule et qui braquent une position
gagnante un jamais de dire maintenant
faut juste convertir mai dernier peut
prendre à deux je pense voilà c'est fait
ils l'ont enlevée sa dalle l'obstruction
donc c'est assez logique tout ça pour
faire de son pas se prendre des coups
pranger 6 ou des rois bouge tour g1
hargne on va tenter de brouiller mais
objectivement si elle juste assez foutu
je pense que nos positions dame b de
hockey
il va échanger les dames poussé à savoir
gagner ici quelques coups et va revenir
à -5 donc le score avant le début de
ciboulette mais il ya déjà quatre partis
qui sont là c'est ça le problème pour
pour fil rouge à terminator à 6
donc j'ai décidé il faut forcer la
qualité au cas où un moment sur le pion
bon il carrément tomber peut-être
n'ont-ils abandonné un bon joueur
d'abandonner un parce que il ya d'autres
joueurs qui auraient pu faire tendre le
score à nancy je vais rendre si kiev
pour l'anah king demain bah écoutes je
pense pas surtout si je commente surtout
si je commande c'est le chat random en
fait je n'ai pas trop le temps et puis
2-2 faudrait que j'aie la clé streaming
de blitz stream qui est gardée secrète
qu'il a sur son ordi à canet sait tous
que nous pouvons déjà qui lui le
problème ou la chaîne se fait ce travail
et donc il est méfiant quoi mais non non
du coup je ferais pas un hacking
en tout cas cette partie intéressante
les deux joueurs ont même honte de temps
donc sur dja qui a tenté une nouvelle
fois de l'attaqué alors accrue des trois
menaces m'a donc sûrement g6 à venir et
puis du hk tu vas partir à un moment où
tu peux reposer donc qui favorise la
tacc comme on a déjà dire si souvent
qu'il va lire trois qui est 6 h 4 et
c'est parti donc logique h4 on veut
faire h5 avec casser ce mur de pions
noirs sur les lois si énorme certain que
même s'affaiblit kg 5
kelly peut venir à peut-être ont
probablement c'est du g4 ou quoi un
moment donc on dit oui avec mon compte
obtient un vélodrome
moi j'ai pas de chaîne youtube quoi en
fin de chaîne youtube de widgets chaîne
youtube mais j'ai pas de chaîne twitch
non plus donc je peux jouer le tournoi
évidemment mon propre nom mais je peux
pas vous le stream est ce qui ce qui est
quand même le but de l'aréna qui quelque
part dans la position s'animer à fond et
objets 4 juillet au f5 c'est parti dans
tous les sens mais oui je peux jouer
avec fable il ça c'est sûr ces gens lui
même doit faire un tournoi une fois
alors c'est un truc tu vas un des points
sur la saison ça pas trop gros intérêt
non plus si je le stream pas mais le
truc c'est une façon j'ai pas de chaîne
donc ce que je fais et pleyel m6 va avec
le territoire
qui est contre attaque sur f2 donc de
l'even peut-être f3 pour soutenir ou un
peu comme tous rêvent de hockey 3 décidé
lorsque j'ai appris j'ai quatre dames
prend j'imagine
et tout n'est pas simple dans cette
position évidemment puisque fou projet 6
peut arriver donc 5 jouer jean [ __ ]
angers 6 voilà c'est fait on va pas
apprendre sur la colonne g parce
qu'aucun ouvrage 5 un moment pour tout
bloquer avec le fou et donc c'est
intéressant
j'ai déjà qui se ramènent avec eux il
peut gagner celle-là pire aux jo il a 13
secondes comme 3 et le roi de l'even est
plus en danger par l'ins l'oni
j'ai dit ça tâche de porter malheur sur
la f1 en lâche 1 dames g3 nombre des
phosphates faut dé 5,3 cette reprise
devrait y fit assez bon seimat ok donc
moins 4 écoutez on sait jamais ce qui
peut se passer
celle là vaut mieux pas la perdre pour
les bonnes en fait et va rejouer cette
petite anglaise avec eux trois donc est
pleine
j'y vais c'est à dire j'avoue à ce n'est
pas de savoir si de toi je connais jpp
je suis très content je suis déjà un
vieux gars combien de temps plus ou
moins une dizaine de minutes
georgia qui ont un petit g5 web ont
sûrement foulée deux tu l'auras pas les
mêmes enjeux sur ces cases noires sera
grande beune à n'avoir qu' et b4 jouer
bon je prends tu donnes b2 du coup parce
qu'on a peut être prendre cali c'est
trop ration va sur un nouveau scan
bon ok on attend ça évite un peu le f4
qu à venir mais vraie position quand
intéressante f4 ok donc une nouvelle
fois on va jouer sur la grande diagonale
et célia qui vient d'arriver
j'ai trois ok vous faire piéger 4 et
dames 3 4 bon un jour quoi pour
l'instant c'est aussi évidemment si on a
toutes les pièces y voir des cas ce
thème là bas il faut surveiller les
maths mais ça peut être l'idée callas 3
voir bien jouer quand même j'aime bien
ce coup ça lui fait une pièce avait
pensé ok c'est 6 de ce parce qu' il
prend la tour il va bouffer j'ai trois
hivers tanger 5 mg/kg cathy bloc ne
menace pas d'un brunch 4 puis 6 h 7e 4
en rognant ouvre tout à fond mais qui a
les cas bien joué je sais pas ce que ça
vaut sa crise de pièces que les vannes
en tout cas ils envoient une nasse où
pranger 49.23 bien joué mais c'est bien
mais ça
si toi prendre qu'à elle prend encore
fait mais je crois que ça il a raté
trois chiens dont qu'il menace la dame
comme seydou j'imagine d'un élève de
hockey fait retour cet échec peut-être
échec de consolation rouaroua monte son
ok bien joué et du coup et quand même
deux pièces de plus pour ferroudja qui
se met en chaîne et les victoires
attention ça serait une énormément de
talent mais il y plus qui a - 3 bons
lorsqu'elle loin 3 mai
bonsoir suit donc
attention les jeunes ont qui change de
variantes qui joue une petite gambie
dame classique plus solide qui a été de
se faire attaquer droit est logique
bon ça fait quand même arrivé de damas
cinq reprises c4 c5 j'imagine qu'ils
disent est peut-être un petit 6,6 à un
moment
donc une pollution assez tranquille est
ce que l'on montre écoute je crois pas
il a été laissé faire club pour
l'instant il s'est pas laissé tomber
quoi on est donc parti n'est pas en jeu
la montre il joue mais la vente par thil
a aucun problème dans le coup il n'y a
pas d'attaqué une pression assez stable
il joue assez vite il va faire du faux
bissett machin enfin il peut une
position stable qui va quoi tour des
huit peut-être mois le temps de vie
j'aime bien voici ce truc comme ça
hockey acih de chasse ce cavalier
bon après si on ne passe pas énormément
de choses mais ça peut jouer parce que
c'est trop et faible en échange et b6
mais ces partis qui peut durer un petit
moment quand même celle là c'est le 5
puis revient car place à toi siégé cinq
s'établissent bien qu'alliée de cinq
variétés tous les f4 donc un rognon par
son fait une partie assez sérieuse assez
solide
c'est bien je de sa part d'être tour des
six sais pas si ça doit pas si mal voilà
c'est le coup qu'il a choisie qui a
élevé trois dames sessad j'imagine bon
niveau les objecteurs kébé 3 mais au
moins y assassiner il va doubler tour
sur la colonne des a5
donc je pense à bize simplement voilà et
c'est cadre d'accords qui arrive quand
même à compliquer la situation avec ce
fou mais ça tu la veux attaquer si on
feb et 4 bon ça va laisser une faiblesse
et peut-être du tour ben quoi ensuite
ok c'est un peu animée la position c'est
moins stable que ce a été et surtout il
ya plus de temps pour les jeunes qui
perd une pièce je crois bon bah écoutez
tout est possible nous dirait plus que
deux points d'écart mais vonn qui a une
bonne position à quelques coups s'est
effondré celle là
fo veut pas perdre quoi je sais pas si
puisque quelqu'un le chrono quelque part
sur le sur le stream officiel hooper
commune tant il reste bon après midi à
perdre cette partie là non plus un mais
bon
notre 4 minutes 30 bon bref on est
obligé de tout bien l'hymne national
disons si rené on part pas celle là il
va gagner un match quand tu y as raismes
gros favoris se serait temps qu'ils en
perdent six sets de suite vous qui ça
quant à la tête au fond du trou que le
prends la confiance mais bon ça fait
quoi si elle y était je crois qui se
rejoue une partie ou de fâcher pas il ya
un mini mini team aqua dans un look et
en bulles est sûre sur john farrell a
annoncé après à quel point dur à dire
ils étaient moins forts clairement moins
fort en blitz mais bellati plus son truc
quoi non plus avec la souris c'est même
pas un vrai budget sur l'échiquier avec
la souris en a vu les années à venir
pouvaient souffrir des foires et donc
donc donc à voir mais bon je les ai
encore pas une arme en de chances de
survie à fuir au jam et au début c'était
quasiment zéro là maintenant ça commence
à être complètement
un scénario improbable ses cannes
possible c'est possible quand même d'en
prendre 5
il s'en laisse pas compter il peut après
un pion il le prend il n'y a pas de
problème direct qui avait le 4 et le
faire d'un prêt 9,5 j'imagine donc
damage trois menaces qui avait lieu aux
quatre y avoir qu'un mac attaquer les
vans apathie simple pour offrir aux jo
écoutez il a pris un pion sur vialatte a
qui peut la gagner après et ils auraient
tous sur la dernière maison j'avais une
gamme qui a eu quatre et six escales lui
de faire les vannes il faut pas qu'ils
réfléchissent trop c'est ce qui faisait
bien dans les deux premières parties de
bullet c'est qu'il souhaitait pas trop
dans la merde autant là
[Musique]
non faut 7 va faire f city va reprendre
ses cinq fautes et 8 je peux comprendre
il prend ses cinq points les autres peut
prendre un f5 s'il envoie ou échange
d'abord un vin ou ne pas y toucher aussi
mais bon attention eyquem qui les sept
comme menace donc fou g5
ok il n'ira pas manquer au 4 x 3 assad
rsa c'est un truc comme ça que 4 x 3
peut-être queyroi g28 foule trop et
chaque ils se gardent de caïx 17 le cas
échéant et la tour déjà qui s'activent
et quatre blocs la colonne faut trois
blocs celle là aussi tu as 3 3 kg
cadeyrn le pion puis on prend comprend
elle veut faire bref trois montées en
réussite rar et quand même bah je crois
que c'est bien pour faire oublier que
les quatre ne peut pas promettre
inquiets des six a dit la patronne du
coup il ya toujours huit
il reprend f5 bon à leuven qui
s'activent aux côtés même si on rêve
d'être hyper dangereux et sûrement
gagnant pour les marques pollution
dommage qu'il ait pme keyyo 400 watts à
défendre sa position mais la f3 b5 f2
bon soit perdant juste pour les blancs
mais faut encore bien faire car ils sont
fous war et à 5 temps comme ça tirait
ont peu ou pas d'effets en 2006
bon ok c'est pas que je sais pas mais
bon il avec ces deux secondes allongé un
truc pas tomber
on a bien joué ça que d'émotions quoi
tout est possible
trois sets bon je crois que c'est
gagnant pour les blancs maintenant donc
nuls mais sept nuls risque de bien sauvé
de bien sauver les bonnes parce que je
pense il ya pas assez de temps pour
peut-être faire deux défaites il doit
rester plus ou moins trois minutes sont
un régal
c'est ça il faut qu'ils gagnent
tellement vite
mais je pense c'est fini maintenant deux
minutes c'est de partir espace bongrand
puissante sera ou non de 30 secondes
hier qu'il peut finir cette partie et
pas une autre
mais bon on va écouter nous dit sueurs
froides besoin de la partie d'avant
était vraiment vraiment gagnants furent
donc sig et celle d'avant
tout se jouait sur 7 6 bon on aura vu un
beau combat
mais après que la mare oignons me semble
au dessus des monts ambulatoire et que
tout peut aller très vite et tout peut
être remis en question
en une petite dizaine de minutes quoi
donc sert déjà six provinces un peu la
section 5 minutes sont un client très
sérieux
ambühl ati déjà au top c'est un des
meilleurs au monde c'est sûr après le
bit c'est plus des échecs quoi que le
budget est donc là encore encore du
retard mais bon attention
non cette berra partie les jeunes qui
jouent au plus vite pour l'instant foule
revient vers des six
et on peut seront composés par ge et 5
qui va partir c'est fait j'ai 5 mai lam
c est bien pour les noirs spécial quand
il apprendra r3 évidemment et il envoie
y lit mieux les bonnes et mieux pour
l'instant une tête d un parti va te
tourner même pour les jeunes qui peut
alourdir un peu le score mais c'était
assez serré c'est un match plus serré
qu'on a eu pour l'instant peut-être
cette saison 2010 9 des speechs est ce
bon 3e biologique il va faire h4 jettera
ensuite les vingt types pour
complètement tout ouvrir d'un message
attention donc qu'il soit là et hkd g3
va arriver
j'ai eu huit attaques le pian elle
valait vers à 7
c'est bien joué ça je crois que les
vannes a raté complètement
il a dû faire tes trois bits plus tôt et
là du coup je te tire ses 5 mai sa
crainte d'un coup il ya des six qui
arrive on sera en français damas 7 ces
collines je ne veux pas de défense trop
à 23,6 ok mais ça chauffe quand même ça
chauffe grave parce qu'il ya une bêtise
qui peut être un problème aussi
assurance que je vous les noms des six
peut-être tout reprend des six ont fait
décidera s'il faut faire qui fait dans
ce sens là alaplaya n'y avait pas que
8,6 match 3 qui est une pièce qui te
font décidemment la d'investissement
mais bon la camsa doit gagner du temps
pour le simple dames 35 et la fourchette
évoquée pour tout matériel partout
auquel evans était gagnant celle là mais
il a perdu mais je crois que ça va finir
soit fini on va te le match c'était
c'était la dernière donc juste un point
d'avancé pour les bonnes c'est
finalement très serré quoi sur la fin de
parcours
mais c'est un beau match et j'espère que
ça vous a plu mais n'oubliez pas donc
demain on se rejoint à midi
sur sur la chaîne chez ce com fr et
des partages de mv elle les partage de
nouvelles dont contre lyon 2 ghz pour la
troisième place à la coupe du monde
et puis aussi évidemment on suivra ce
qui se passe entre entre entre dingle
radjabov voilà à écouter les autres à
tous une bonne soirée
allez les verts ces dix masques de
wolfsburg et puis on en parle demain
allez ciao